la séance est ouverte l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions au gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur philippe berta
merci monsieur le président ce cette
question s'adresse à monsieur bruno le
maire -ministre de l'économie et des
finances monsieur le ministre
s'il est un enjeu mise en exergue par la
crise sanitaire que nous traversons
c'est l'importance stratégique de la
filière santé aussi bien pour la vie de
nos concitoyens que pour l'indépendance
de notre pays en ce domaine nous devons
agir fort et vite parce qu'il est urgent
de relever pleinement ce défi est de
rendre au pays de pasteur et de curry
son excellence au service de notre bien
le plus précieux la santé en amont nos
laboratoires de recherche sont en quête
d'un nouveau souffle
la réussite de la loi de programmation
pluriannuelle de la recherche ou lppr
est cruciale pour leur apporter
l'oxygène nécessaire pour de nouvelles
avancées scientifiques et pour améliorer
les capacités de transfert et de
valorisation mais c'est aussi en aval au
stade préindustriel des essais cliniques
au stade industriel de la production en
passant par la mise sur le marché des
médicaments que les difficultés se
posent avec le plus d'acuité lourdeurs
administratives aider les non compétitif
absence de grands fonds d'investissement
pour financer des essais cliniques
politique de fixation du prix annualisé
dissuasive et cetera les goulots
d'étranglement donc en effet pas il est
symptomatique de constater que dans le
grand pays de la virologie qui est le
nôtre
cazaux mais un quasiment aucun des
antiviraux sortie de nos laboratoires de
recherche n'a été commercialisé par nos
entreprises et ne font partie des essais
cliniques en cours
nos découvertes scientifiques s'envole
systématiquement l'étranger au détriment
de la centurie de la santé de nos
concitoyens c'est d'une politique
globale intégrant la filière
industrielle santé d'un bout à l'autre
de nos priorités nationales de nous
avons besoin il s'agit aussi bien de
rééquiper nos laboratoires en santé
d'outils et d'équipements français je
n'existe pratiquement plus ce qui a
accru les situations de pénurie pendant
la crise que de mettre en place un
écosystème favorable à la valorisation
de l'innovation en france et des
success-stories économique
monsieur le ministre suite aux
enseignements de cette crise quelles
sont vos intentions pour notre filière
industrielle de santé je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole
est à madame agnès pannier rue nager
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
berta vous avez raison de souligner
l'importance de la filière santé et de
son caractère stratégique et d'ailleurs
nous n'avons pas attendu cette crise du
comique 19 pour nous en saisir puisque
dès 2018 nous avons mis en place le
conseil stratégique des industries de
santé avec une feuille de route très
clair une soixantaine de mesures qui
couvre les différentes questions que
vous avez souligné d'abord en amont
toute la question des autorisations
administratives pour faire de la
recherche clinique l'accompagné l'a
favorisé réduire les délais puisque la
france ne brillait pas au plan européen
par sa performance
ces mesures ont été prises elles sont
aujourd'hui en vigueur on peut toujours
faire mieux mais elles font partie de
notre plan de route
deuxième élément soutenir l'innovation
et la r&d l'innovation publique
l'innovation privé nous nous y employons
nous venons de lancer avec frédéric
vidal un plan de soutien à l'innovation
et à la recherche de 550 millions
d'euros dont 100 millions d'euros pour
lé ps pc dont ceux évidemment de la
filière santé
le troisième élément c'est
l'industrialisation et la réimplantation
de sites industriels de production non
seulement en france mais en europe pour
éviter de faire face à des ruptures par
rapport à cela nous avons également
avancé puisque nous avons eu des
discussions avec un certain nombre de
laboratoires pharmaceutiques sur la
façon dont le prix peut leur permettre
de ré envisager de réimplanter des sites
en france c'est le fameux article 18
c'est l'évolution du même du prix du
médicament nous prévoyons une enveloppe
pour la première fois depuis des années
qui est en augmentation sensible pour
les médicaments innovants + 3 % et une
enveloppe pour l'ensemble des
médicaments qui est également en
augmentation
pour toutes ces raisons nous allons
continuer continuer à pousser aussi une
production et une approche stratégique
de la santé au niveau européen qui
devrait se concrétiser dans un hyper
si madame le maire la parole est à
madame virginie dubly muller monsieur le
premier ministre
107 c'est le nombre de violences que
subissent chaque jour nos forces de
l'ordre en france
face à ce constat dramatique le premier
flic de france a choisi de se soumettre
à la haine anti-flic prêt à bafouer la
présomption d'innocence pour donner des
gages à la haine il autorise même des
manifestations rassemblant vingt mille
personnes en plein état d'urgence
sanitaire ou un policier noir se fait
insulté de sale vendus ou en appel aux
armes ou des casseurs ravage le mobilier
urbain
le tout pendant que la garde des sceaux
se fait juge et partie en proposant de
recevoir une famille endeuillée qui
refuse la légitimité d'une enquête en
cours tels françois hollande avec
léonard da votre gouvernement accepte
que la justice soit rendue par la rue ou
sur les réseaux sociaux plutôt que dans
un tribunal
ce serait ridicule six ans n'était pas
indigne monsieur le premier ministre il
est indispensable de lutter contre
toutes les formes de racisme ou qu'elle
sévisse mais il est impensable de
laisser accuser l'état et la police de
racisme de l'est s'est américanisée la
france alors que notre histoire n'a rien
de comparable
face à ceux qui détestent la france
heureusement nous sommes encore beaucoup
à l'aimer et à vouloir la défendre
contre la menace terroriste dans les
mouvements sociaux pour faire respecter
le confinement sans matériel les forces
de l'ordre ont toujours été là ahmed
mera battre clarissa jean-philippe
jessica schneider jean baptiste salvin
ont été tués par des islamistes
ils sont le visage de la france la
dictature de l'émotion ne doit pas faire
oublier leur travail alors je vous le
demande
en reprenant les termes de votre
ministre de l'éducation nationale
etes-vous la république en marche où le
communautarisme en vadrouille
allez vous défendre l'honneur de la
police en refusant qu'elle soit livré à
la vindicte populaire
etes-vous de ceux qui défendent des
forces de l'ordre ou de ceux qui veulent
la mettre à genoux
merci va débuter la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
merci beaucoup
aussi beaucoup
monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs
s'il vous plaît non mesdames et
messieurs et madame notre collègue a
posé une question importante
écoutez la réponse que le premier
ministre entend lui donner
vous avez la parole monsieur le premier
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée dans votre question vous
évoquez un point fondamental la question
du racisme dans notre société et vous
évoquez la question spécifique des actes
racistes dans un certain nombre
d'institutions et puis vous fait dire
des choses qui malheureusement je me
permets de vous le dire madame la
députée ne sont exacts
un certain nombre des membres du
gouvernement
je voudrais prendre votre question dans
ce qu'elle a de plus sérieux et de moi
pardon mais bassement polémique le plus
sérieux c'est la réponse que notre pays
importe vos actes racistes le plus
sérieux c'est la façon dont nous sommes
capables de dire tous ici que le racisme
n'est pas acceptable qu'il n'est pas le
choix de la france que la france a fondé
son système juridique intellectuelle et
philosophique sur une idée sain que les
hommes naissent libres et égaux en
droits et que la république ne reconnaît
aucune distinction sur le fondement de
la couleur de peau ou sur le fondement
de la religion 7
oui mais c'est ce que je réponds
[Musique]
la vérité et nous le savons tous ici
c'est que la république s'est fixé des
principes incroyablement simple mais
ambitieux et que notre pays doit être à
la hauteur de ses principes à la hauteur
de ces principes là notre pays doit être
à la hauteur de ses principes
c'est donc un combat collectif est un
combat individuel que nous faisons
contre une faiblesse de l'esprit contre
des préjugés contre quelque chose qui
est profondément enraciné je le crains
dans l'âme humaine et que nous devons
génération après génération combattre
pour éradiquer
g je les dis madame la députée respect
et confiance dans la police nationale et
je pense que nos concitoyens ont respect
et confiance dans la police nationale
mais parce que j'ai respect et confiance
dans la police nationale
je porte avec le ministre de l'intérieur
une exigence vis-à-vis de tous les
dépositaires de l'autorité publique et
qui ici est singulièrement sur ses bancs
peut dire que nous ne devrions pas être
exigeant à l'égard d'une personne
porteuse de l'autorité publique
nous sommes donc exigeants nous sommes
respectueux et nous sommes confiants
la police nationale la france la france
la police nationale la gendarmerie ne
sont pas racistes mais chaque fois
chaque fois qu'un acte chaque fois qu'un
acte ou un propos avérés et raciste
alors il est important que l'ensemble de
notre pays réagisse vous êtes d'accord
sur ce point
moi aussi c'est ce que nous disons
respect confiance exigences c'est la
ligne qui est porté par ce gouvernement
c'est la ligne qui doit prévaloir c'est
la ligne sur laquelle toujours je me
battrai merci merci monsieur le premier
ministre la parole la parole est à
monsieur luc carvounas et à lui seul
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
près de 12 millions de français se
trouvent en chômage partiel sur france 2
jeudi soir dernier bruno le maire
jugeait qu'une relocalisation
industrielle était nécessaire pour
l'avenir de notre pays et pourtant dans
ma commune d'alfortville dont je suis le
nouveau maire le groupe sanofi ferme son
centre de recherche et de développement
cela va entraîner la suppression sèche
de 124 emplois dans mon département du
val de marne le groupe renault qui a
reçu un prêt de 5 milliards d'euros par
l'état fermera d'ici 2022
son usine de choisy le roi cela fera
disparaître près de 400 emplois nous
étions d'ailleurs tous les élus locaux
mobilisés samedi auprès des salariés au
gouvernement je dis que nous sommes tous
pour une souveraineté sanitaires que
nous voulons tous une transition
écologique industriels malheureusement
entre les discours et la réalité des
fêtes c'est le grand canyon
ma question est la suivante pouvez vous
nous préciser les détails de vos
intentions quant à la relocalisation et
la transition industrielle de notre pays
et puis puisque je vois qu chrono il me
reste du temps je vais vous dire mes
chers collègues au moment de quitter le
parlement après neuf années de mandat
que je vous donnerai à tous un salut
républicains à votre ensemble de mes
collègues sur tous les bons de notre
assemblée
j'adresse plus particulièrement mais
plus affectueuses penser aux membres de
mon groupe à mes deux présidents d'abord
olivier faure et valérie rabault je vous
dire monsieur le président richard
ferrand qu'à mes yeux vous êtes un
président qui représente bien notre
institution et qui la défend et je veux
vous en remercier je salue le formidable
travail réalisé quotidiennement par les
fonctionnaires de notes
l'institution après la crise sociale des
gilet jaune et la crise sanitaire du coc
vide j'ai mais juste le veut que l'état
prenne enfin conscience que nos
territoires sont la deuxième jambe sur
laquelle nous appuyer notre pays dans
l'intérêt de tous nos concitoyens et à
vous tous mes chers collègues
n'oubliez jamais la belle mission qui
est la vôtre celle de porter la voix de
la nation et de réaliser le meilleur
pour nos compatriotes je vous souhaite à
tous et à toutes bonnes chances je
remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci merci chers collègues avec nos
félicitations pour votre élection et
nouveaux de succès dans l'exercice de
votre mandat la parole est à madame
agnès pannier une hache et secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député carvounas
d'abord félicitations au nom du
gouvernement pour le nouveau mandat que
vous prenez qui est amanda de proximité
un mandat à hauteur d'homme et dont nous
savons l'importance et merci pour le
travail réalisé sur ces bancs au service
de la démocratie
vous posez la question notre politique
industrielle je veux dire qu'elle est
aujourd'hui au coeur de notre politique
économique
je suis fier de faire partie d'une
majorité qui a recréé l'emploi
industriel dans ce pays je rappelle que
ça n'était pas arrivé depuis 2002 2000 à
nous avons dû faire face à des
suppressions d'emplois industriels
chaque année sans interruption en 2017
en 2018 et en 2019 nous avons recréé de
l'emploi industriel
un peu moins de 30000 emplois
industriels nets ce n'est pas
extraordinairement élevé mais c'est le
début d'une reconquête industrielle dont
nous devons être fiers c'est aussi la
france qui est le premier pays qui
accueillent les projets
d'investissements industriels de
l'étranger c'est d'également la france
qui est ouvert plus de sites industriels
qu'elle n'en a fermé ces trois dernières
années
je veux réaffirmer car aujourd'hui nous
sommes confrontés à une crise
effectivement sans égal et dans cette
crise fort de ce que nous avons
construit ces trois dernières années
nous sortons notre épingle du jeu vous
parlez de localisation dans l'automobile
c'est un milliard d'euros 1 milliard
d'euros d'investissements qui ont été
engagées qui vont être engagées par les
constructeurs et les équipementiers de
premier rang pour réimplanter des
sites en france je pense à valeo à
faurecia à pessah et un renault pour les
citer c'est également en ce sens que
nous travaillons dans l'industrie de la
santé
ils nous feront prochainement des
annonces autour de ce plan d'action
c'est l'aéronautique sur lequel nous
venons d'annoncer un plan qui nous
permet de maintenir notre production et
nos pratiques madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur laurent furst
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
ce n'est pas sans émotion que
j'interviens pour la dernière fois dans
7/6 6/2 cycle ayant été réélu maire de
la ville de molsheim en alsace mesdames
et messieurs je vous invite tous à venir
visiter cette commune alsacienne
si je prends la parole monsieur le
ministre c'est simplement pour dire que
j'ai peur sur le premier ministre peur
pour l'avenir de mon pays qui s'abîme à
coups de dette
soyons clairs je ne critique en rien les
plans de relance indispensable
aujourd'hui comme après la crise de 2008
mais je déplore ces années où pendant
que l'europe du nord équilibrer ses
comptes la france jouait la cigale
résultats avant la crise la dette
publique était de 35 mille cinq cents
euros par français est de 87 mille euros
par français occupant un emploi
les français savent t-il qu'avant la
crise si les comptes publics avait
dégagé un excédent de 30 milliards
d'euros
il aurait fallu cent ans pour rembourser
la dette oui mais avant la crise lorsque
l'état percevait 100 euros il en
dépensait 142 c'est dans ce contexte que
notre pays a été mis à l'arrêt générant
une fonte des recettes et une explosion
des dépenses lorsque l'état est en
déficit toute dépense nouvelle est
financé par l'emprunt
ce qui m'inquiète ce n'est pas tant les
dépenses liées au plan de relance que
toutes ces dépenses structurelles qui
pèseront pour longtemps sur le budget
c'était hier les gilets jaunes c'est la
loi de programmation militaire son
augmentation demain le ségur de la santé
les hausses de salaires promises aux
enseignants le dispositif de risque du
risque dépendance
le tout
financé à grands coûts d'emprunt sur le
premier ministre la situation est
extrêmement difficile et je ne voudrais
pas paraître donneur de leçons mais j'ai
peur j'ai peur que le noeud coulant de
la dette etc l'angle notre pays à la
première montée des taux d'intérêt j'ai
peur qu'un jour le pays se noie dans un
océan de dettes et j'ai peur d'un
journal tchernobyl budgétaire monsieur
le premier ministre
dites-nous simplement s'il ya un montant
de dette publique à partir duquel vous
considérez la france en situation de
danger
merci chers collègues félicitations à
vous aussi et tous nos voeux de succès
dans le mandat à la tête de votre
commune la parole est à madame agnès
pannier rue nash et que les terres
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances merci monsieur le
président donc je vais également nom du
gouvernement vous féliciter pour votre
nouveau mandat et les travaux accomplis
sur ses bancs et je serai ravi de
visiter molsheim la dette publique va
dépasser 120% du pipe cette année c'est
une progression de 20% c'est une
progression qui est homogène avec celles
des autres pays qui sont placées dans
les mêmes situations que nous et cette
progression et ce plan que nous avons
mis en oeuvre plus tôt plus rapidement
que nos voisins c'est ce que nous disent
les entreprises qui ont des sites en
france mais également à l'étranger
ce plan il va permettre de soutenir nos
entreprises et de poser les fondamentaux
de la croissance future c'est ça le sens
de notre action car la croissance future
c'est elle qui va nous permettre d'aller
chercher les financements d'aller
obtenir la croissance de ressources
fiscales de ressources sociales qui
permettra effectivement de rembourser
notre dette
il faut raisonner en retour sur
investissement vous le savez monsieur
faust lorsqu'on investit dans
l'innovation
lorsqu'on investit dans la technologie
lorsqu'on investit dans les compétences
des hommes
alors nous nous créons la croissance
future et c'est en ce sens que nous
menons notre action et puis c'est faire
fi des trois années qui ont été déroulés
avec des résultats économiques de grande
qualité
je crois me souvenir que la dépense
publique a été stabilisé la dépense
les recettes fiscales ont plutôt la
pression fiscale a diminué c'était la
première fois depuis bien longtemps
voilà effectivement le sens de notre
action une action qui favorise
l'économie les entreprises et derrière
les entreprises l'emploi et la sérénité
sociale je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
mme fadila khattabi
merci bien monsieur le président madame
la ministre
il y a quelques jours pour faire suite à
la crise sanitaire
la ministre du travail annonçait un plan
massif de soutien à l'apprentissage en
prenant un engagement ferme
les jeunes ne seront pas la variable
d'ajustement de la crise
eh bien ces propos sont pleins de bon
sens il nous faut donner effectivement
une perspective d'avenir à notre
jeunesse et à l'apprentissage et
l'apprentissage effectivement est une
des réponses pertinentes au chômage et à
la précarité des jeunes dans notre pays
en effet cette voie d'excellence
contribue chaque année à l'insertion
professionnelle et donc à l'insertion
sociale pour des milliers d'entre eux
avec la réforme pour la liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel
le gouvernement a fait de
l'apprentissage l'une de ses priorités
et les résultats sont là
368 mille contrats signés en 2019 2020
soit une croissance de 16 % du jamais vu
dans l'histoire de l'apprentissage
aujourd'hui avec la crise que nous
traversons l'apprentissage a encore
besoin de nous la jeunesse de france a
besoin de vous aussi je me réjouis du
plan de soutien ambitieux présenté jeudi
dernier à savoir un milliard d'euros
consacré consacré pardon à soutenir les
entreprises qui continueront à recruter
des apprentis et ce jusqu'à bac + 3 un
budget sera également dédié à
l'équipement numérique pour que chaque
apprenti puissent bénéficier en début de
parcours d'un ordinateur
une mesure qui vient renforcer l'égalité
des chances comme cela a été précisé la
mobilisation territoriales et notamment
des acteurs économiques jouera un rôle
essentiel pour la pérennité de notre
système d'apprentissage il faudra bien
sûr aussi compter sur les centres de
formation aussi ma question est la
suivante en cas de baisse drastique du
nombre d'apprentis
quelles mesures de soutien financier
seront prévues à destination des cfa
afin de les accompagner au mieux dans
cette phase de transition je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur laurent qui est 3e ce qui
serait d etat chargé de la protection et
de la santé des salariés
merci monsieur le président excusé
l'absence de madame la ministre du
travail
ça va bien se passer vous allez voir
excusé l'absence de la mainmise du
travail qui réunit autour d'elle les
partenaires sociaux pour travailler sur
le pacte pour l'emploi
et vous savez que le sujet aujourd'hui
des risques pour notre économie à
l'issue de la crise sanitaire sont
importants et qui le il est utile que
les partenaires sociaux seraient dit sur
ce sujet alors un malade la députée je
sais votre investissement sur le sujet
de l'apprentissage et je sais votre
connaissance de cette réalité
vous avez bien décrit dans votre
question à la fois la dynamique qui a
été porté dans la loi de la liberté pour
choisir son avenir professionnel mais
aussi le rôle de tous les acteurs de la
formation et tous ceux que ce soit au
niveau territorial aussi au niveau des
employeurs et des partenaires sociaux de
manière à avoir plus de 16 % à la
rentrée dernière d'apprentis nous avons
je crois collectivement ici réussi à
changer le regard changer le regard que
nous avions collectivement peut-être à
tort sur l'apprentissage
l'apprentissage est bien une voie
d'excellence et d'ailleurs nous le
voyons avec des progressions
significatives autour des métiers de
l'artisanat mais aussi des métiers des
services et du tourisme
vous m'interrogez à madame la députée
sur la façon dont le gouvernement entend
soutenir l'apprentissage
vous avez vu les récentes déclarations
de la ministre du travail sur ce sujet
notre choix c'est de rassurer l'ensemble
des acteurs et notamment des cfa en
rendant le plus possible accessibles
l'emploi à ces jeunes avec des aides
significatives
8000 euros par pour la première année
pour les contrats d'apprentissage pour
les personnes de moins de 18 ans du 18
ans et 5000 euros dans les plus de 18
ans cette réalité eh bien ça ne va
permettre de sécuriser sécurisé à la
fois les entreprises qui vont avoir
recours à des enfants l'apprentissage
mais aussi vous le savez permettre aux
jeunes de rentrer en cfa merci n'ont pas
encore de contrat hier ces mesures
permettront de stimuler l'apprentissage
la parole est à la marianne dubois
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
l'apprentissage a connu en 2019 un fort
engouement avec une hausse de 16% il est
vrai nous partions de très loin une
hausse que le gouvernement attribue à sa
réforme de 2018 alors même qu'il
déclarait à son lancement que ses effets
ne se ferait pleinement sentir qu'en
2020 quand on regarde de près la hausse
par territoire est fortement corrélée
avec les politiques régionales mises en
place un paradoxe puisque les régions
ont été dépossédés de la gouvernance de
l'apprentissage deuxième paradoxe les
secteurs économiques sont dorénavant
totalement investi mais chaque projet de
loi de finances en un peu plus les
ressources de nos chambres consulaires
avec l'arrivée du coc vide 19
l'apprentissage s'est retrouvé dans une
situation très délicate très délicate
aussi à cause d'un déconfinement très
lent et très cadré décidées par le
gouvernement alors alloué 1 milliard
d'euros à l'apprentissage en piochant
rappelons le dans les fonds européens
est certes une belle annonce mais
pouvez-vous nous assurer que ce plan de
sauvegarde soit pleinement efficace
qu'ils ne réduisent pas à néant la
revalorisation de l'apprentissage engagé
qu'il ne soit pas un effet d'aubaine
pour certains secteurs et soit modulé
selon les secteurs d'activité qui ne
soit pas contre productif sur l'emploi
qu'il corrige les défauts de la réforme
de 2018 et en particulier la
métropolisation de l'apprentissage au
détriment des territoires ruraux
qu'adviendra-t-il des candidats
apprentis au mois de février 2021 s'ils
n'ont pas trouvé de patron
une hypothèse malheureusement
vraisemblable puisque les principaux
effets de la crise économique sont
attendues pour le second trimestre 2009
1 et premier trimestre 1021
notre jeunesse va-t-elle s'engager vers
une formation susceptible d'être
interrompu au bout de six mois
même si leur présence en cfa pour être
étendue sans contrat jusqu'à 12 mois
monsieur le premier ministre au delà du
milliard d'euros votre plan de relance
permettra t-il d'éviter les écueils
développer je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur laurent pietrasinski celle de
terres d'état chargé de la protection et
de la santé des salariés
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés madame la députée
marianne dubois
vous m'interrogez sur la portée des
mesures que nous avons évoqué tout à
l'heure avec madame la question de la
députée fadila khattabi et vous
questionnez sur l'impact qu'ils qu'elles
pourront avoir je crois que la première
des choses c'est effectivement de
maintenir le niveau d'apprentis que nous
avons dans notre pays que les deux
mesures de mesure que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure à savoir la prime unique de 8000
euros pour les plus de 18 ans et de 5000
euros pour les moins de 18 ans est un
premier élément la possibilité pour
l'ensemble des jeunes de rentrer dans un
cfa et pour les cfa d'être rémunéré au
cou contrat alors qu'ils n'ont pas
encore d'entreprise est aussi un élément
sécurisant dans notre objectif est bien
de maintenir la dynamique
d'apprentissage et faire que nous ayons
à la rentrée 2020 le vin niveau
d'apprentis que ce que nous avons à la
rentrée 2010 9
vous n'avez interrogé aussi sur sur le
fond le devenir de ce qu'ils sortent de
l'apprentissage et bien ceux qui sortent
de l'apprentissage c'est l'objet des
séquences de travail qui ont lieu en ce
moment avec les partenaires sociaux et
madame la ministre du travail
justement pour construire la meilleure
proposition en matière de pacte pour
l'emploi car je crois qu'on peut vous
rejoindre madame la députée et bien la
génération les jeunes ne doivent pas
être les victimes de cette crise
sanitaire
elle nous devons collectivement assumer
nos responsabilités vis-à-vis d'eux
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur bastien la
chaux merci monsieur le président dix
pour cent de récession un million de
chômeurs en plus
sixième extinction de masse des espèces
vivantes après l'australie des incendies
gigantesques en sibérie l'effondrement
menace nous ne pouvons pas continuer
comme avant et pourtant c'est ce que
vous faites
il ne s'agit pas de relancer
de bifurquer des milliards pour air
france renault derichebourg des
milliards sans contrepartie ni sociale
ni environnementale vous subventionnez
des licenciements pour satisfaire vos
amis du cac 40
vous n'avez aucune vision ni pour la
france ni pour l'intérêt général vous
laisser perdre des savoir faire
indispensables à la souveraineté du pays
et à la transition écologique
tout cela par pure idéologie parce que
vous refusez la simple idée de planifier
mais la planification n'est pas une idée
neuve en france le général de gaulle
lui-même l'a voulu en 46 elle a permis
le redressement de la patrie alors
aujourd'hui évidemment il ne s'agit plus
d'électrifier le pays de construire des
autoroutes d'apporter le téléphone dans
tous les foyers
aujourd'hui il s'agit de planifier la
bifurcation écologique la france un
semis ou fait quatre propositions pour
sortir notre pays de l'ornière parer à
l'urgence avec de grands travaux
écologiquement utile la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments
la rénovation des canalisations qui
laisse échapper 20 % d'eau la remise en
route d'un réseau ferré danse dans tout
le territoire le développement des
énergies propres y compris pour le
transport relocaliser grâce à un
protectionnisme solidaire
mettez la france aux avant postes face
aux nouvelles frontières de l'humanité
que sont la mer l'espace et le numérique
ne laissez pas ces secteurs devenir des
zones de non droit d'exploitation
aveugle des ressources enfin agissez de
manière coordonnée en rétablissant le
commissariat général du plan
ces propositions sont faites de bonne
foi êtes vous prêt à vous en saisir
merci chers collègues la parole à madame
agnès paillard une hache et secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
lachaud
je vous remercie pour votre enthousiasme
sur la rénovation thermique cela fera
plaisir à mon collègue julien de
normandie qui travaille sur le sujet
depuis trois ans avec emmanuelle wargon
avec le ministère de l'économie et des
finances est sincèrement
j'attends que vous approuve y évoquer
tous les plans que nous sommes que nous
comptons passer sur ces sujets là je
pense également que votre enthousiasme
sur le ferroviaire fera chaud au coeur à
mon collègue jean baptiste djebbari qui
lui aussi a largement entamé cette
transition et ne vous a pas attendu pour
effectivement trouvé cet objet comme
étant utiles à la patrie n'est pas
nécessaire d'avoir un commissariat
général au plan simplement une équipe
gouvernementale
aligné sur les objectifs de transition
écologique et de transition numérique
car nous ne parlons pas nous agissons
monsieur la chaux nous agissons avec des
mesures concrètes avec un plan de
soutien aux entreprises qui est
évidemment accompagné de contreparties
en matière écologique
je prends l'exemple d'air france la
suppression des avions qui se perdent
sur des destinations à moins de 2h30 de
paris en réseau ferroviaire
voilà une mesure qui est concrète et qui
peuvent être mis immédiatement en action
alors monsieur la chaux je vous invite à
peut-être relire les différents plants
nous proposons les plans de
relocalisation à milliards d'euros dans
l'automobile le plan sur l'aéronautique
de ce matin qui est sans égal je crois
depuis 50 ans pour soutenir cette
filière nous sommes particulièrement en
avance et où au lieu de remplacer par
des primes à la conversion en avions qui
polluent beaucoup par un avion qui
polluent encore beaucoup
nous allons financer une transition
massive pour des avions à l horizon 2026
sa consommation sobre énergétiquement et
totalement qui est décarbonée en 2035
voilà des actions précises concrètes et
qui ré industrialiser notre pays
merci madame la ministre que la chaux
nous attendons toujours la rénovation
thermique est ce que vous faites sur le
ferroviaire c'est fermer les petites
lignes vous faites le contraire de ce
que vous dites encore une fois vos
propositions à nous
vaud c'est du vent et la réalité c'est
que le marché est incapable de résoudre
le problème mais des matches où la
parole est un bonhomme and is ok d'air
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la ville et du logement
pendant confinement tout au long de la
crise sanitaire
malgré les difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent au quotidien comme tous les
français
les habitants des quartiers prioritaires
ont été exemplaires
loin de l'image négatif renvoyé par une
minorité qui a choisi de troubler
l'ordre public
je pense notamment aux auteurs des
rodéos motorisés il s'est exprimé dans
nos quartiers et s'exprime encore en ce
moment une très belle solidarité
association citoyen engagé entreprises
collectivités
beaucoup d'acteurs se sont mobilisés au
coeur des quartiers pour aider les aînés
les familles toutes les personnes
isolées ou en situation de précarité le
soutien de l'état par les moyens que
vous avez débloqué a été essentielle
parfois vital pour la grande majorité
d'entre eux les jeunes et les enfants
des quartiers ont vécu le confinement en
famille en veillant respecter les
consignes sanitaires en tentant de
poursuivre leur scolarité dans des
conditions difficiles parfois dans des
logements sur occupés pour certains
insalubre souvent dans des appartements
sans balcon sans jardin ces jeunes et
ces enfants que ne voit pas que le
n'entend pas méritent notre
reconnaissance pour les efforts
consentis
parce que beaucoup d'entre eux ne
pourront pas partis en vacances cet été
il nous faudra de nouveau mobiliser les
acteurs de ces territoires pour que
cette jeunesse puisse bénéficier de
temps de partage est d'épanouissement à
travers le sport et les loisirs
il nous faudra également proposer des
sorties culturelles et éducatif des
vacances en dehors de leur quartier
monsieur le ministre alors que vous
venez d'annoncer le plan vacances
apprenantes qui viendra en complément
des dispositifs déjà existants comme
ville vie vacances pourriez nous nous
préciser les moyens qui seront déployés
pour donner la possibilité aux enfants
et aux jeunes des quartiers prioritaires
d'apprendre et de s'abaisser va dès cet
été
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est à monsieur julien de normandie
ministre chargé de la ville et du
logement
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée la question qui se pose à
nous et qui se posent à toutes les
personnes ici dans cet hémicycle
c'est que voulons-nous pour cet été nous
avons eu un printemps sacrificielle nous
avons eu nous avons eu un printemps pour
qui beaucoup a été synonyme d'un
possibilité d' empêchement et la
question fondamentale est-ce que après
ce printemps triste ce printemps
sacrificielle nous souhaitons un était
heureux 1 et et d'opportunité ou pas et
la question elle se pose
particulièrement pour les enfants de
notre république
elle se pose particulièrement pour les
enfants de ces quartiers pour qui
probablement le confinement a été
beaucoup plus difficile et pour ses
enfants de la république avec jean
michel blanquer r nous avons décidé de
mettre en place un dispositif innovant
qui je crois pourrait même intéresser ce
côté de l'hémicycle
si le prêter l'oreille à ce que nous
portons comme projet pour notre jeunesse
et ce projet c'est permettre à 200 mille
enfants des quartiers de partir de leur
quartier pour aller dans d'autres
territoires et d'avoir des colonies
apprenantes ses colonies et apprenantes
le principe est assez simple c'est de
permettre d'avoir à la fois ce moment
d'évasion ces nouveaux horizons
géographiques culturelles
mais en même temps d'avoir un rattrapage
scolaire lorsque ce rattrapage scolaire
est nécessaire et ses colonies de
vacances à prenante dès le projet de loi
de finances rectificative nous
proposerons que vous puissiez adopté un
financement de l'ordre de 80 millions
d'euros de 80 millions d'euros pour
pouvoir les financer la solidarité elle
s'est exprimée pendant cette période
elle doit continuer à s'exprimer pendant
cet été et cet été doit être 1 dt pour
nos jeunes avec eux
cette oxygénation nécessaires merci
madame la députée merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à mme adams et si
longtemps mayer merci monsieur le
président j'ai ceci ma collègue michel
victory empêché à cette question alors
monsieur le ministre 15 millions de
bénévoles un million cinq cent mille
associations constituent une exception
sociale culturelle française extrêmement
importante
un patrimoine économique aussi est un
bien commun alors qu'elle soit
associations employeuses investi d'une
mission de service public ou association
composée uniquement de bénévoles leur
travail est considérable pendant le
confinement elles se sont organisées
pour continuer à servir l'intérêt
général
je pense à l'aide alimentaire en
particulier au soutien aux personnes
isolées jusqu'à la fabrication de
masques et visière elle porte la
solidarité la culture et l'innovation et
nous leur disons ici notre
reconnaissance
vous avez supprimé la réserve
parlementaire au motif avancé d'une
opacité et sans doute parce que nous
n'avions pas été assez nombreux a ancré
dans le territoire un dispositif
collégiale participatif donnant la
parole aux bénévoles de ces associations
c'est un potentiel de 700 millions
d'euros sur cinq ans qui s'est ainsi
évanouie compenser certes je vous la
corde mais en partie seulement par le
fdd à nous avons perdu sur toutes les
lignes en transparence
nous ignorons jusqu'à la date de la
réunion des commissions et les
associations aussi souvent hélas en
souplesse avec des critères qui n'émane
plus du terrain et en puissance
d'intervention puisque les crédits ont
été réduits allons-nous monsieur le
ministre revoir ce dispositif
c'est à dire majorer la dotation
certaines associations sont au bord du
gouffre mais aussi mettre en place un
mécanisme innovant d'attribution des
subventions laissant sa place au citoyen
aux parlementaires souhaitant s'investir
dans ce domaine et permettant aussi aux
associations de venir défendre leur
dossier
l'exigence de transparence et la
reconnaissance que nous leur devons
comme notre souci de travailler
autrement dans un domaine qui s'y prête
bien nous y invite fortement
merci chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur gabriel a tall secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
cécile untermaier merci d'avoir rappelé
le rôle des associations pendant cette
crise du coronavirus et ce confinement
nous avions eu l'occasion de le faire à
plusieurs reprises dans cet hémicycle
si notre pays a tenu c'est beaucoup
grâce à elle beaucoup grâce à ces
associations beaucoup grâce aux
bénévoles aux français qu'ils ont
rejoint la réserve civique et qui ont
permis à des missions absolument
essentiel vital de se tenir partout sur
notre territoire et nous devons leur
apporter notre reconnaissance et dans
les réflexions et les travaux qui vont
nous anime et sur la relance et sur les
enseignements que nous tirons de cette
crise évidemment que la question de la
vie associative est profondément
centrale et la question de la
participation citoyenne aussi quand on
parle de vie associative
on parle de citoyen par principe parce
que ce sont des citoyens qui font vivre
les associations et parce que les
associations agissent pour les citoyens
je vais pas revenir sur le débat que
vous avez évoqué réserve parlementaire
fdv à moi je crois profondément au f dva
je pense que c'est un très bel outil qui
a permis l'an dernier d'apporter des
subventions à près de dix mille
associations 80% de ces associations ou
entre 0 et 2 salariés ce sont des
petites associations un très bel outil
mais un outil que nous pouvons faire
progresser et nous avons commencé à le
faire la question de la participation
des parlementaires dans les commissions
fdv à a beaucoup animé ces débats elle a
été adoptée dans la proposition de loi
portée par sarra el aissi qui attend sa
dernière lecture au sénat et donc dès
les parlementaires pourront participer
aux commissions du fonds développement
de la vie associative
mais il faut aller plus loin et moi je
rejoins totalement votre proposition on
avait déjà eu l'occasion d'en parler de
faire participer les citoyens le
gouvernement
il est prêt on l'a montré avec la
convention citoyenne pour le climat à
cette participation citoyenne est ce que
je peux annoncer en réponse à votre
question c'est que nous allons
travailler pour que l'année prochaine
des commissions citoyenne puisse venir
appuyer les décisions du sève d'hévéa
pour l'attribution des subventions je
crois que nous progresserons beaucoup
encore en permettant aux citoyens de
participer puisqu'il en va de la vie de
nos territoires et de la vie de la
nation je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole d'un monsieur jean-françois
porte à rillieux merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre des
transports airbus comme l'ensemble du
secteur aéronautique est fortement
impacté par la crise du commis 19 le
plan de soutien à la filière qui a été
annoncée aujourd'hui répondent donc un
besoin impérieux
à la crise sanitaire a succédé pour le
groupe européen une crise d'ordre
économique commercial industriel et
désormais sociale avec de fortes
inquiétudes sur l'emploi et de réelles
menaces sur toutes les entreprises de la
filière à toulouse la baisse des
cadences de production a déjà des
répercussions pour les chaînes
d'assemblage de l'a320 a330 et a350 et
avec l'arrêt de l'a380 la situation
s'avère très préoccupante pour le
secteur
d'autant qu'en plus de la crise actuelle
l'arrivée de l'a321 xlr va bouleverser
le carnet de commandes des avions long
courriers les spécialistes estiment en
effet que ce nouveau monocouloir à long
rayon d'action pourrait supplanter ses
concurrents à l'extérieur mais également
à l'intérieur même du groupe
c'est la raison pour laquelle anticipant
ces évolutions direction les syndicats
ont négocié et signé en janvier 2020 un
accord de compétitivité pour implanter
la chaîne d'assemblage de l'a321
en lieu et place de celle de l'a380 sur
le site toulousain jean luc lagardère
monsieur le ministre ne pensez-vous pas
que cette décision stratégique que
d'installer la chaîne d'assemblage de
l'a320 heures à toulouse mérite
absolument d'être confirmée et doit
nécessiter la plus grande attention à
l'absence d'une garantie définitive
l'écosystème toulousaine pourrait perdre
le caractère diversifié de ses activités
un atout qui lui permet aujourd'hui en
fonction des évolutions de cadence de
ses programmes de garantir l'activité à
long terme pour des centaines
d'entreprises et des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois
c'est aussi l'assurance de renforcer
notre souveraineté industrielle dans un
secteur clé pour la croissance de notre
pays
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur jean baptiste djebbari
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs et député monsieur le député
porte à rillieux merci pour cette
question qui me permet de revenir sur le
plan inédit présenté par le gouvernement
ce matin en soutien au secteur
aéronautique
la crise sanitaire vous l'avez du a eu
un impact majeur sur le secteur
aéronautique une diminution de 95 % des
vols au niveau mondial et une très forte
réduction de la production des rosneft
civils en sont je crois d illustration
marquante pour autant
l'aéronautique est et doit rester une
filière d'excellence française il s'agit
de notre premier un premier secteur
d'exportation et 300000 emplois
ils sont liés partout dans le territoire
et notamment chez vous en occitanie
comme pour de très nombreux secteurs
l'état a répondu présent et la stratégie
que nous présentons que nous avons
présenté ce matin s'articule autour de
trois axes d'abord la réponse à
l'urgence en soutenant les entreprises
en difficulté et en protégeant leurs
salariés ce sont plus de 560 sites
partout en france et plus de cent dix
mille salariés qui ont été par exemple
concernés par le dispositif d'activité
partielle
ensuite en soutenant les pme et les
outils du secteur pour accélérer leur
transformation avec des outils
financiers dédiés
enfin en accélérant massivement la
recherche aéronautique pour accélérer la
décarbonation des transports est
préservée vous l'avez dit notre
souveraineté industrielle nationale et
européenne nous engageons ici un
tournant majeur vers une génération
d'avions plus sobres en carbone avec des
objectifs concrets
un premier avion hybride régional à
l'horizon 2027 et le successeur vert de
l'a320 à l'horizon 2035
c'est un défi important considérable
mais nous sommes collectivement près je
tenais à remercier michael nogal de
toutes les contributions qu'il a pu
faire à ce sujet et pour répondre
rapidement sur l'a321 je partage avec
vous l'idée qu'il s'agit d'un outil
essentiel a aussi deux toulousains nous
avons eu l'occasion de dire que le
principe de l'implantation de la chaîne
n'est pas remise en cause mais que le
carnet de commandes est cette dynamique
est fait aujourd'hui l'objet de la salle
nombre d'incertitudes
soit les assurer que le gouvernement
soutient ce projet et se tiendra
fermement à vos côtés
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
à la mélodie jacquier la forge
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je souhaite vous interpellez
aujourd'hui sur les inquiétudes des
représentants des producteurs de lait et
de fromages et gpao paix suite à
l'épidémie de covin 19 filière est
problématique que je connais bien dans
mon département l'isère où est produit
le saint marcellin les producteurs les
éleveurs les fermiers ont fait face à
des difficultés liées à des pertes de
débouchés compte tenu de la fermeture
des restaurants et de la restauration
collective et des achats orientée vers
les produits de première nécessité
plutôt que des achats dits plaisir par
les consommateurs et la période de forte
production laitière a aggravé la
problématique le comité pour le saint
marcellin a tout mis en oeuvre pour
aider ces opérateurs et ces derniers ont
réussi à se réorganiser et à trouver des
solutions pendant le confinement mais
certains ont tout de même une situation
qui est critique aujourd'hui en raison
d'une baisse des ventes allant de - 25 à
moins 95%
il leur a fallu se résoudre à jeter du
lait et des fromages invendus le conseil
national des appellations d'origine
laitières a aussi proposé plusieurs
leviers d'action comme l'aide au
stockage d'urgence ou la mise en oeuvre
d'un mécanisme pour couvrir la perte
nette de chiffre d'affaires et les
destructions de marchandises bien avant
la crise du coc vide nos agriculteurs
traversaient déjà une crise sans
précédent
ils ont malgré tout répondu présents
pendant le confinement pour nous
permettre de ne manquer de rien et pour
nous fournir une alimentation de qualité
je tiens aujourd'hui à les remercier de
nouveau au sein de notre hémicycle
je tiens à saluer leur rôle central
pendant cette période
face à ces difficultés je tiens à
attirer votre attention sur les demandes
formulées par les représentants des
appellations fromagère et sur le risque
qui pèse sur les nombreux producteurs
laitiers transformateurs de notre pays
monsieur le ministre
quelle stratégie va être mise en oeuvre
pour conserver ces milliers d'emplois
locaux et le savoir faire gastronomique
de ces filières que je suis certaine
le monde entier
nous envie je vous remercie merci japon
avec la parole et à monsieur didier
guillaume ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
vous l'avez citez dans votre
circonscription vous avez de
saint-marcellin mais il ya beaucoup
d'autres fromages sous signe de qualité
que l'ensemble des députés
m et d'ailleurs monsieur bricout à
l'instant n'arrêtait pas de parler de
maroilles et je veux saluer le conseil
départemental de l'aisne qui pour aider
la filière acheté quatre mille maroilles
monsieur deal est là et les a distribués
à des associations alimentaires savez le
gouvernement suit l'ensemble des
l'ensemble des filières pas uniquement
celle ci est aujourd'hui je dois dire
que nous avons pu réussir en travaillant
avec l'interprofession à répondre à peu
près à l'ensemble de leurs
revendications et notamment celle ci
nous avons fait beaucoup pour
l'assouplissement des signes de qualité
ça nous a d'ailleurs été reproché par
certains mais il était indispensable que
l'inao s'adapte à la situation pour
permettre aux verts à ceux qui vendent
les fromages sous signe de qualité de
pouvoir le faire de pouvoir permettre la
congélation de voix permettre la retenue
nous avons obtenu de l'union européenne
la possibilité d'avoir des aides aux
marchés tout cela c'est une bataille que
nous avons mené qui a été très important
nous avons participé aussi avec
l'interprofession à la communication
fromage y sont qui est bien passé dans
l'ensemble des des médias comme d'autres
et d'ailleurs je vois que monsieur
djebbari est très intéressé par cette
campagne parce qu'ils mangent beaucoup
de fromages aussi dans son dans son
département
enfin je veux remercier les régions et
les intercommunalités qui ont aidé cette
interprofession à ça à s'en sortir parce
que réellement
ça a été des victimes collatérales de la
fermeture des chr dans la mesure où
beaucoup de fromages aop sont vendus en
restaurants sont en restauration
collective et ça n'a pas été le cas et
enfin par rapport à votre dernière
question
le plfr 3 va passer dans l'hémicycle
dans peu de jours et dans les
exonérations qui seront qui seront mises
en place dans le plfr 3 cette filière
pour en bénéficier voilà madame la
députée merci monsieur le ministre la
parole de monsieur stéphane peu
merci monsieur le président chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
à première vue on pourrait y voir un
paradoxe la seine saint denis
département le plus jeune de france
métropolitaine vient de payer le plus
lourd tribut à la pandémie du coc vide
19 avec une surmortalité de près de 130%
malheureusement les causes de cette
situation sont désormais bien connus le
rapport parlementaire lucide et
courageux de nos collègues
cornut-gentille l'écho cuando avait déjà
amplement démontré que la rupture
d'égalité républicaine s'y déclinent
pour toutes les missions régaliennes de
l'état qu'il s'agisse de l'éducation de
la sécurité la justice ou encore de la
santé vous même monsieur le premier
ministre le 31 octobre dernier vous vous
êtes rendus sur place avec plusieurs
ministres
vous y avez affirmé à juste titre la
seine saint denis ne se contentera pas
de mots elle attend des actes des
solutions de l'efficacité et vous avez
présenté un plan d'action de 23 mesures
monsieur le premier ministre et moi plus
tard je vos paroles tarder à devenir des
actes or la crise du coc vide 19 a
cruellement attester de la justesse du
diagnostic
faute d'investissements d'équipements et
de services publics
la vie est plus difficile la santé de
ses habitants plus fragiles leurs
conditions de vie plus dégradée pourtant
les habitants de la seine-saint-denis ne
mérite pas ce traitement à bien des
égards ce sont eux qui ont le plus
contribué à tenir la france debout
durant cette crise en forme et on peut
les applaudir
ce sont eux qui ont le plus contribué à
tenir la france debout durant cette
crise en fournissant les plus gros
bataillons de la première et de la
seconde ligne et aujourd'hui ils
s'inquiètent après avoir été les
premiers de corvée seront ils les
premiers sacrifiés de la crise sociale
monsieur le premier ministre la seine
saint denis est en état d'urgence
d'égalité les mesures que vous avez
annoncé ont soulevé un certain espoir et
ma question est simple entendez vous les
mettre en oeuvre et surtout dans quel
délai merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député vous étiez présent
nous étions ensemble 31 octobre dernier
en seine saint denis pour l' annonce de
ce plan ce plan répondait à des
interrogations multiples formulées par
les habitants de cet indice par les
parlementaires de seine saint denis
il répondait à un travail qui avait été
menée collectivement il répondait aux
rapports que vous avez cités rapport
éclairant rapport dur dans le constat
qu'il faisait d'une inégalité d'une
fragilité exceptionnel de ce département
depuis longtemps rapport qui pointe et
le fait que à ce département hors normes
il fallait des réponses hors norme c'est
le sens du plan que j'ai présentées de
23 mesures mais je vous remercie de
l'avoir rappelé vous avez raison de dire
que le paradoxe entre le département le
plus jeune de france métropolitaine et
celui qui paye le plus lourd tribut à
l'épidémie de covile alors même que l'on
sait que c'est les populations les plus
fragiles et singulièrement les plus âgés
qui sont les victimes les plus courantes
malheureusement de cette maladie j'ai
dit à l'occasion de l'engagement des
travaux du ségur de la santé que la
carte des décès
correspondait bien trop souvent bientôt
tristement à une autre carte celle des
inégalités sociales et la seine saint
denis est l'illustration de cette vérité
de la plus grande difficulté d'avoir
accès aux soins de la plus grande
difficulté à avoir des politiques de
prévention santé qui sont indispensables
des plus grandes comorbidités bref de
toute une série de facteurs
il est beaucoup trop il n'ya pas
pratiquer de les décrire ici mais nous
les connaissons nous les avons
identifiés le paradoxe n'est donc qu'à
par an c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous voulons mettre en place des mesures
hors norme pour ce département hors
norme alors vous dites
certes un espoir peut-être né mais il
faut que ces espoirs cet espoir se
traduise par des actes
les actes je veux le dire clairement
monsieur le député les voici la prime de
fidélisation annoncé vous savez cette
prime de 10 mille euros qui sera versée
aux fonctionnaires qui reste au bout de
cinq ans de services effectifs en seine
saint denis sera applicable à partir du
mois de juillet prochain les décrets
sortiront d'ici là cinquante policiers
supplémentaires dans les deux nouveaux
quartiers de reconquête républicaine de
la courneuve et de saint-ouen et 50
nouveaux officiers policiers officier de
police judiciaire pardon seront nommés
les effectifs seront au complet au 1er
septembre prochain est un des éléments
de ce rapport avait été de montrer
notamment en matière d'officier de
police judiciaire
le très grand décrochage le très grand
manque en vérité de ses personnels
indispensables au bon fonctionnement de
la justice
s'agissant des sujets immobilier la
garde des sceaux va présenter dans les
semaines qui viennent un schéma
directeur qui définira les modalités de
l'extension du tribunal judiciaire de
bobigny elle est décidée elle était
annoncée
il faut que ce schéma directeur puisse
être rendu public enfin en matière
éducative c'est 200 enseignants qui vont
bénéficier cette année d'un contrat de
prêt professionnalisation et nous avions
indiqué combien il était nécessaire dans
ce département de mettre en oeuvre cet
instrument afin de permettre le pré
recrutement est donc la mobilisation des
talents au service de l'éducation en
seine-saint-denis le préfet de la seine
saint denis a vu son enveloppe de
dotation de soutien à l'investissement
public local majorée pour soutenir les
investissements dans l'immobilier
scolaire au premier rang desquels le
dédoublement des classes répéré plus
évidemment il y en a beaucoup
il faut donc beaucoup d'investissement
et l'enveloppent en question a été
augmentée se sont donc monsieur le
député des mesures effectives qui sont
prises tout indique et je l'espère
qu'elles commenceront à se voir à partir
du mois de septembre prochain
mais je ne fais aucune illusion vous non
plus d'ailleurs et tous les gens qui
connaissent la situation spécifique de
la seine saint denis sont dans notre cas
nous savons que c'est un travail lent
régulier cohérent durable massif qui
permettra de produire les effets que
nous attendons merci monsieur le premier
ministre
la parole est à monsieur françois groupe
''le merci monsieur présente sur le pré
ministre
ma question d'ailleurs dans la droite
ligne de ce clown dire notre collègue
peu mais avec une différence notable
vous allez le comprendre
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire le
val d'oise est malheureusement un des
territoires les plus touchés de
l'épidémie avec presque 1500 morts
hôpitaux ehpad compris lors de votre
allocution du 28 mai dernier il était
même le dernier département
métropolitain en rouge au niveau de
quatre indicateurs retenus lors du diane
et pointe de santé publique france le 4
juin
la situation était toujours préoccupante
puisque le taux d'incidence il était
toujours de 12 personnes par rapport à
une manne national de 5 et le
pourcentage de tests positifs étaient
près de 4%
quand la moyenne nationale était de 2%
qu'elle est monsieur le premier ministre
il est apprécié de la situation
sanitaire aujourd'hui dans le val d'oise
par ailleurs avait ou à ce stade des
éléments d'explication qui permettrait
de comprendre pourquoi ce département
était l'un des plus exposés au virus que
les autres et si oui pouvez vous nous
les communiquer à titre personnel je ne
suis hélas pas surpris depuis plusieurs
années j'alerte désespérément sur la
difficulté de notre territoire et
particulièrement sur l'est du
département
elles sont économiques sociales et
nécessairement sanitaire puisque tout
est lié
comme cela est le cas en seine saint
denis oui avec cette crise due qu'au vu
de la situation catastrophique de l'est
département du val d'oise a éclaté au
grand jour
monsieur le premier ministre il est
urgent de proposer des solutions pour ce
département et sa partie est qui souffre
depuis trop d'années il faut je crois à
analyser les causes profondes de ces
difficultés avant d'élaborer et de
mettre en oeuvre une grande stratégie
pour y remédier dans cette optique est
il prévu au niveau gouvernemental
une étude approfondie soient réalisés
pour comprendre la situation sanitaire
mais aussi économique et faire des
préconisations est-il par exemple prévu
un grand plan
pour notre territoire comme ce fut le
cas pour nos voisins de la
seine-saint-denis l'est du département
ayant les mêmes caractéristiques
sociales économiques que la
seine-saint-denis
à mon niveau je suis prêt à soutenir
cette démarche en rédigeant avec ma
collègue part qu'un rapport
parlementaire
à l'image de ce qu'avait fait nos
collègues cornut-gentille les cours
d'eau pour la seine-saint-denis
si bien entendu la survie nationale il
fait droit merci chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur le président merci mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
françois pupponi j'étais hier dans votre
département du val d'oise précisément à
argenteuil pour assister à une séance
une organisation dans un gymnase de la
commune de dépistage qu'on appelle
dépistage aller vers à destination de
publics qui sont éloignés des structures
sanitaires et qui a fait le lien entre
le département la commune la rs la
préfecture l'hôpital d'argenteuil très
mobilisés mais également des
associations remarquable et que je tiens
à saluer à l'occasion de cette réponse
et qui font des démarches d'aller vers
les publics précarisés éloignés de
l'offre de soins habituels et qui
expliqué monsieur députés en grande
partie ce que vous avez souligné
à savoir une incidence est à dire une
circulation du virus plus dense plus
importante dans ce département comme la
seine saint denis où le val d'oise
qu'ailleurs le diagnostic il est connu
monsieur pupponi vous êtes engagés sur
ce terrain depuis un certain nombre
d'années on appelle ça les inégalités de
santé et les inégalités de santé elles
sont criantes encore dans notre pays et
les inégalités de centaines ou sautent
au visage à l'occasion d'une épidémie
qui fait des ravages plus important dans
les quartiers populaires qui conjugue la
promiscuité le faible accès aux soins et
une comorbidité avec des facteurs de
risque qui sont peut être plus important
encore qu'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il
faut faire le maximum d'efforts et c'est
pour ça que le maximum d'efforts a été
réalisé depuis le premier jour je pense
aux centres de santé aux maisons de
santé au centre kovy de plus qui ont été
développés dans le val d'oise avant
encore qu'il soit développé sur le reste
du territoire
néanmoins une embellie au tableau
monsieur le député il n'a jamais été
question de pointer du doigt le
département pour le déclasser d'aucune
manière
mais juste pour faire le constat que la
circulation du virus nous imposait
d'être encore plus vite
aujourd'hui la situation s'est améliorée
l'incidence est descendu à 8,7 pour cent
mille la part de passages aux urgences
pour suspicion de kobe est descendu à 1
25% le taux de positivité des tests et
lui descendu à 3,4 pour cent c'est plus
encore que la moyenne nationale
mais c'est en dessous des indicateurs
d'alert que nous avions élaboré ce qui
nous permet d'être optimiste pour la
suite
il ne faut pas relâcher nos efforts dans
le val d'oise comme partout ailleurs
nationale monsieur le mini la parole est
à monsieur hubert wulfranc monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre de la
santé le 16 juin dans une semaine
partout en france et soignants vont vous
demander des comptes
vous le savez à l'augmentation de
salaires créations d'emplois
augmentation des capacités hospitalières
bref vous connaissez depuis plus de deux
ans leurs revendications et vous les
ignorez alors le gouvernement réagit en
urgence aux demandes de soutien du
secteur privé dont sollicitant des
contreparties mais notre système de
soins publics a d'ores et déjà lui tout
donner sans recevoir
après des hommages mérités mais
tellement appuyé qu'il met parfois mal à
l'aise coude et moi monsieur le ministre
les soignants eux-mêmes vos décisions
contestées sur le don de congé entre
salariés et un système de primes
insatisfaisant eh bien il est temps
d'apporter des réponses durables séjour
ou pas c'est dur ou par ségur ou pas
vous avez déjà tout en main les députés
communistes vous demande donc avec
fermeté de crédibiliser enfin votre
action en annonçant sans délai ce que
vous mettez sur la table des
négociations pour faire sauter le verrou
de l'austérité à l'hôpital public
l'aig la parole que monsieur olivier
véran ministre des solidarités et de la
santé monsieur le député wulfranc merci
de votre question qui me permet
d'aborder la question de l'hôpital
public de la valorisation des soignants
de celles et ceux qui ont sauvé des vies
et jour après jour semaine après semaine
dans notre pays et qui attendent
beaucoup aujourd'hui de l'état à juste
titre et qui recevront beaucoup de
l'état à juste titre les mots du
président de la république
les mots du premier ministre lorsqu'il a
inauguré lui-même le ségur de la santé
atteste bien la volonté des pouvoirs
publics de reconnaître à leur juste
valeur la place de celles et ceux qui
prennent soin de nous quand nous nous
sommes nous mêmes en attente de soins
l'heure est venue monsieur le député et
l'heure est venue aussi de s'interroger
au delà de la question de la
valorisation des soignants à l'hôpital
de comment nous pouvons tirer à qui
tirait profit des acquis de la crise du
coc vide de la formidable innovation de
l'ingéniosité du génie de nos soignants
qui en ville à l'hôpital dans le secteur
médico social ont réussi à faire sauter
un certain nombre de verrous de carcans
pour faire évoluer par eux mêmes un
système de santé dont on disait qu'il
est qu'il était ce sans doute sclérosé
par endroits trop pyramidale organisé en
silos entre la ville et l'hôpital le
sanitaire et le médico social
monsieur le député on ne nous aurions pu
faire comme d'autres ont fait nous
donnait six mois un an que sais-je
confier des missions pour faire le
diagnostic n'est pas le choix que nous
avons fait le choix que nous avons fait
c'est de se donner un mois pour faire
des retours d'expérience dans les
territoires avec celles et ceux qui ont
vécu la crise pour qu'ils puissent nous
renseigner nous informer qu on puisse
s'enrichir de leurs expériences et de
mener en bonne et due forme je sais vous
êtes sensibles ce député des
négociations salariales en vue non
seulement de revaloriser les salaires
mais de penser également à la gestion du
quotidien la qualité de vie au travail à
la formation à l'évolution des métiers
des carrières à la transformation
nécessaire de notre système de santé
on va vite monsieur le député croyez moi
croyez moi on va vite il y à de l' envie
collective partagée d'un côté de l'autre
de la table et je suis d'ailleurs gré
aux députés aux parlementaires de tous
les groupes sénat comme à l'assemblée
nationale et qui viennent participer
activement à ce ségur nous avons besoin
j'ai besoin de votre retour d'élu de
terrain pour nous guider dans cette
poste gestion de la crise
merci monsieur le ministre vous dégoûter
bouffon admettez monsieur le ministre
que les parlementaires que nous nous
sommes sont en droit d'être d'attendre à
ce jour
à cette date est bien des fourchettes
sais combien c'est sans ses 300 euros
d'augmentation
quel est quel plan d'investissement à
quelle hauteur qu'elle vous donnez nous
des fourchettes
donnez nous un calendrier que nous nous
retrouvions pas au mois de septembre
devant des décisions définitives que
nous ne saurions après cela merci
monsieur le député la parole à madame
caroline fiat
[Applaudissements]
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
estimé hier que la pandémie de covic 19
s'aggrave
même si la copie de recul en france nous
devons nous préparer à une éventuelle
recrudescence
pourtant force est de constater que vous
n'apprenez pas de vos erreurs à
l'hôpital nous continuons de travailler
en situation dégradée sur blues en sacs
poubelles pénurie de masques ffp2 mais
qu'attendez vous pour apporter du
matériel de protection professionnels
midazolam propofol curare les pénuries
de médicaments sont nombreuses
qu'avez vous fait pour y remédier
incompétence ou mépris il ya quinze
jours vous avez vidé de son contenu
notre proposition de loi créant un pôle
public du médicament
vous faites ainsi jeu des industries
pharmaceutiques et de leurs actionnaires
en refusant d'assurer notre souveraineté
sanitaire que vous faut-il encore une
hécatombe une pénurie de gand s'annonce
allez vous attendre que l'on soit à
nouveau au pied du mur votre arrogance
vous aveugle en refusant de regarder la
situation en face vous mettez en danger
la population
finalement que proposez-vous pour
l'instant des promesses si ce n'est une
prime inégale et pas pour tous dans le
cadre du ségur pour la santé vous
arrivez déjà vous mettre à dos les
paramédicaux les médecins de ville
exclu des négociations c'est également
le cas des syndicats de jeunes médecins
que heureusement la justice vous impose
de réintégrer aux discussions comble du
mépris
les préfets interdisent les
manifestations de soignants le 16 juin
le message des soignants est clair
ne donnez pas de jour de congé pour nous
offrir un chèque vacances posé un jour
de congé de ses joints et venez nous
aider à obtenir de réels moyens pour
notre profession et pour nos
établissements de santé monsieur le
ministre vous êtes médecin vous le savez
les soignants connaissent l'importance
des gestes barrières nous saurons les
rappeler le 16 juin il y à peu tous vous
nous applaudissent y ait aujourd'hui
vous nous interdisait de manifester vous
ne nous donnez pas les équipements
nécessaires pour travailler
allez vous nous donner le droit que de
manifester nous ne voulons pas d'un
défilé le 14 juillet nous voulons
manifester le 16 juin
merci chers collègues la parole et à
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé madame la
députée la députée nous sommes soutenus
ont tous les deux nous sommes d'ici -
ministre et vous parlementaire madame la
députée carolyn fiat
j'ai envie de vous dire il ya des
questions des éléments dans votre
question que je partage qui sont
importants vous êtes la première à nous
reprocher l'absence de dialogue
regardez comment vous en voulez vous
initier le dialogue avec nous il n'est
pas nécessaire il n'est pas nécessaire
de faire des procès en arrogance en
interdiction de manifester en équipement
nous faisons madame fiat le maximum pour
protéger les soignants depuis le premier
jour dans notre pays
sans nier les difficultés que nous
pouvons avoir pour fournir suffisamment
de masques envie condition que chacun eu
largement l'occasion de connaître depuis
seule semaine après semaine
chacun sait les difficultés que nous
avons eues à fournir suffisamment de
médicaments anesthésiques dans les
hôpitaux français mais plus généralement
dans les hôpitaux européens et aussi
outre atlantique
à l'heure où la consommation de
médicaments explosé de 2000% madame la
députée ce n'est pas nous qui avons
rejeté la proposition de loi que vous
avez déposé sur un pôle public du
médicament
vous avez retiré le texte avant l'examen
en séance après l'examen de ce texte en
commission
et ce n'est certainement pas moi
ministre des solidarités la santé qui
pose quelques avis d'interdiction que ce
soit de manifester pour quelle que soit
niant que ce soit dans ce pays
c'est sous l'autorité des préfets que
les choses se déroulent même la députée
vous êtes venu et je vous en remercie
travailler
travailler dans le cadre du ségur de la
santé vous êtes venu à mon ministère la
semaine dernière vous avez pu vous
exprimer nous avons pu échanger
je vous invite à continuer à faire des
propositions mais ont besoin de tout le
monde
la santé n'est ni de droite ni de gauche
ni en marche la sentel et universelle
elle est pour tous les français et
aujourd'hui ce qu'attendent de nous les
soignants ce ne sont pas des polémiques
c'est une revalorisation c'est un
travail collectif pour que la situation
change et que plus jamais nous soyons
dans des difficultés comme celle que
nous avons connue au niveau mondial face
à une épidémie aussi dévastatrice que
celle ci merci monsieur le ministre la
parole comme monsieur arnaud viala merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la santé
la crise du coronavirus a révélé
l'extraordinaire mobilisation de notre
système de santé et de nos personnels
soignants en première ligne pour faire
face à l'épidémie et qui ont réussi par
leur abnégation et leur dévouement sans
borne a déjoué le pronostic de collapsus
de notre système hospitalier
cette crise accélère à la prise en
compte d'une attente très forte et
généralisée d'une réforme de l'hôpital
public français dans sa gouvernance
c'est moyenne le continuum des soins et
c'est indispensable
vous avez annoncé le lancement du ségur
de la santé et c'est à son sujet que je
souhaite vous interroger tout d'abord
pour connaître le calendrier de ces
réformes
l'attenté est très grande et ni les
soignants de nos hôpitaux ni nos
concitoyens ne pourront supporter des
promesses qu'ils ne seraient pas suivies
d'effets rapides ensuite sur les
modalités de ce travail les sujets sont
nombreux mais comporte notamment un
volet territorial qui à nos yeux est
capital afin de garantir un maillage
efficace de nous et de nos hôpitaux
à ce stade ni le parlement ni les
acteurs locaux des territoires ne sont
associés à vos travaux
leur réussite repose pourtant sur une
vision ascendante plus qu'exclusivement
descendante des besoins des populations
et des réponses à y apporter
enfin sur les moyennes madame busin
avait annoncé plusieurs plans successifs
pour l'hôpital et des millions d'euros
injectés sans que l'on sache vraiment
d'où il venait
et où il serait affecté votre réforme
est d'une tout autre envergure
à combien estimez vous et comment
assurez-vous le financement je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur olivier verrey ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
député arnaud viala je vous remercie
pour cette autre question qui porte sur
le ségur de la santé et vous l'avez dit
vous-même ça ne portera pas que sur
l'hôpital même si le volet hospitalier
est très important mais c'est l'occasion
aussi d'aborder la question la médecine
de ville abordé l'un sans l'autre ce
serait conforté des six lots dont on dit
qu'ils ne communiquent pas suffisamment
et c'est aussi abordé la question du
médico social et notamment des ehpad
dont la crise sanitaire nous a bien
montré l'importance d'avoir un
raisonnement global et collectif
monsieur le député vous posez la
question de l'association des élus aux
travaux sachez que l'association des
maires de france l'association des
départements de france
l'association des régions de france font
partie intégrante des travaux du ségur
depuis le premier jour ils ont pu
d'ailleurs s'exprimer et qu'il m'arrive
régulièrement d'appeler moi même des
présidents de collectivités
territoriales pour avoir leur avis
personnel sur la question tant la
question et l'enjeu territoriale est
fondamental dans le pilotage de notre
système de santé nous devons retenir les
enseignements de la crise avec les
atouts qu'elle a portées et moi je
reconnais aux agences régionales de
santé
une action remarquable dans deux dans
des situations extrêmement complexe mais
je reconnais aussi que le rôle avec les
collectivités territoriales
l'interaction et que les collectivités
toria territoriales a montré tous les
atouts sa richesse pour notre système de
santé et doit être encouragé sur la
question de la place des parlementaires
monsieur viala je vous invite à votre
tour à venir au ministère il y a deux
séances encore cette semaine auxquelles
je participe de questions réponses des
changes de retours d'expériences avec
les parlementaires pour recueillir la
proposition un certain nombre de vos
collègues parlementaires je pense à
monsieur perdu notamment ont participé
pour votre groupe parlementaire déjà la
semaine dernière à ces travaux
enrichissons nous enrichissions nous
donnons retour d'expérience de nos
propositions on peut avancer ensemble on
peut repenser la place des collectivités
il faut savoir quelle collectivité dans
quelles circonstances
avec quels leviers d'action financiers
et vous verrez que la question du
calendrier
elle est certes importante mais elle ne
nous empêche pas d'avancer
et pour vous pour dire les choses nous
aurons fini début juillet au plus tard
c'est l'engagement que j'ai pris
merci monsieur le ministre je suis le
député sur le ministre merci quand je
parlais de concertation territoriale
je faisais allusion à ce qui me paraît
être indispensable c'est à dire au delà
d'une association des parlementaires
dans leur ensemble une association des
acteurs locaux de chaque territoire afin
que la réponse soit personnalisé et puis
vous ne m'avez pas répondu sur le
périmètre budgétaire de la réforme que
vous portez merci monsieur le débuter la
parole est à madame monique iborra merci
monsieur président créer une nouvelle
branche de la sécurité sociale comme le
gouvernement a proposé dédié à la perte
d'autonomie l'inscrire dans la loi dès
aujourd'hui comme les députés de notre
groupe et de notre majorité l'ont décidé
et comme nous l'avons voté hier soir en
commission spéciale c'est reconnaître
que ce modèle social auquel nous sommes
particulièrement attachés comme tous les
français je modèle a besoin d'être
revisitée et adaptée courageusement car
vecteur aussi des inégalités touchant
notamment les populations les plus
fragiles le secteur du grand âge
en fait partie avec son corollaire
certaines fois représenté par la perte
d'autonomie
ceci nous a incités au vu des exigences
démographiques sociétal financière est
tout simplement humaine à légiférer en
inscrivant dans la loi organique la
création historique d'une cinquième
branche
annoncée par tous les gouvernements de
droite de gauche
cependant jamais réalisées jusqu'à ce
jour mesure mais au delà cette création
devrait être accompagné par un projet de
loi grand âge autonomie ambitieux et
très attendu celui ci devrait prévoir
une refonte globale de la politique du
grand âge sur tous ses aspects
ce projet de loi
devraient préconiser de nouveaux modèles
notamment pour les ehpad et
l'organisation des services à domicile
créer des synergies qui ont fait
récemment prades d'efficacité et donc
supprimer des cloisonnements en
revisitant les gouvernance locale
de nombreux rapports s'en sont fait
l'écho il nous paraît maintenant qu'il
est urgent d'agir dans ce domaine en
changeant le regard porté sur le grand
âge en france en saluant la
détermination du gouvernement si pour
avoir envisagé la création de cette 5ème
branche
pouvez-vous nous a dit merci madame le
député la parole à monsieur olivier
viron ministre des solidarités et de la
santé madame la députée monique iborra
hier la commission spéciale en charge de
l'examen du texte qui porte transfert de
dette vers la cades s est l'occasion
d'examiner un texte que je qualifie
d'historique
ça fait depuis 1945
depuis 1945 que le périmètre de la
sécurité sociale n'avait pas été élargie
à un nouveau risque ou une nouvelle
branche et ça fait 10 à 15 ans et je ne
jette la pierre à personne parce qu'on
sait que c'est très compliqué c'est des
financements qui sont importants
c'est un travail qui est très important
aussi amené que la perte d'autonomie est
touche 10 à 15% de la population
pas comme la maladie ou le chômage qui
peut toucher une partie plus importante
est que ça peut être plus confortable de
se dire qu'on verra plus tard
mais sauf que plus tard on peut pas
parce que le mur démographique il arrive
le papy boomeur baby boom laisse place
au papy boom et qui nous faut penser le
modèle médico-social penser des ehpad à
l'échelle humaine penser la volonté des
personnes qui avancent en âge et qui
souhaitent rester davantage chez elle
conserver un maximum d'autonomie
pensez aussi la demande qui est fait
année après année par les nombreux
soignants qui s'épuise dans les ehpad de
pouvoir compter sur davantage de
collègues pour pouvoir faire preuve de
bien traitance pour apporter les soins
prodigué les soins qui sont
indispensables pour accompagner nos
aînés jusqu'au dernier jour de leur vie
cela nécessitait un engagement très fort
le premier ministre en a décidé ainsi il
s'y était engagé et la création de cette
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
est ainsi un événement historique qui
devrait être suivi par d'autres
évènements que j'espère tout aussi
historique d'abord l'élargissement du
périmètre de la sécurité du but du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour que la
représentation nationale puisse débattre
des efforts financiers que la nation
doit faire pour nos aînés et ensuite un
projet de loi à doc sur la perte
d'autonomie de manière à penser une
politique de l'offre rénover moderniser
accompagné augmenter le niveau de
formation les compétences la
rémunération tous ces sujets là sont
majeurs ils sont devant nous cette
première pierre que vous posez à travers
l'adoption de ce texte et que le
gouvernement accompagne cette première
pierre est fondamentale et une
correction historique et la sécurité
sociale si la parole est à madame
isabelle valentin merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des solidarités et
de la santé nous sortons d'une terrible
pandémie
il était de notre devoir de protéger nos
aînés les directeurs des établissements
et l'ensemble des personnels ont fait
seul
un travail exceptionnel et je tiens à
les en remercier très sincèrement la
gestion de cette crise sanitaire au
niveau de notre système de santé a été
catastrophique
les ars n'ont pris aucune décision aucun
accompagnement et se sont retranchées
dans la simple analyse statistique
ce n'est pas vraiment ce que l'on
attendait d'eux avec le déconfinement
une nouvelle page se tourne
de nouveaux protocoles et de nouvelles
mesures doivent être mises en place les
familles attendent des réponses claires
le 11 mai dans le plan de déconfinement
du premier ministre aucune mesure
d'assouplissement n'a été envisagée ce
n'est que tardivement la semaine
dernière contraint et forcé par les
associations de familles de résidents
que vous avez enfin annoncé un nouveau
protocole de visites dans les ehpad à
compter du 5 juin
ces mesures demeurent très contraignante
alors que les cafés les restaurants
groove peu à peu les résidents des ehpad
et les familles demeure placé en liberté
conditionnelle après plus de deux mois
de gestion de crise lé directeur des
ehpad et les personnels de santé sont
épuisés ils se sentent désarçonné par
des directives des ars qui aujourd'hui
sortent de leur réserve
en fin de crise et qui contredisent les
protocoles nationale votre politique et
sans arrêts contradictoires et
incohérentes
monsieur le ministre n'oublions pas que
le maintien du lien social pour nos
aînés est vital il y a urgence et ce
d'autant plus que l'on observe un
phénomène de glissement chez les
personnes âgées qui peuvent se laisser
aller
quand elle se voit quand elles ne voient
plus leurs proches
l'isolément risque de produire des
conséquences psychologiques encore plus
grave que l'épidémie alors monsieur le
ministre
quand allez-vous prendre des mesures
pérennes et pragmatique pour assouplir
les mesures sanitaires dans les pages et
redonné une lueur d'espoir à nos aînés
merci la parole était monsieur olivier
verrey ministre des solidarités de la
santé
madame la députée isabelle valentin
votre question je la comprends et votre
émotion je la partage ça a été parmi les
décisions les plus difficiles que nous
ayons eu à prendre que de demander un
confinement chambres pour des personnes
âgées en perte d'autonomie que
d'interdire les visites des familles
c'était très dur croyez moi très très
dur cette décision je les ai prises en
concertation systématique avec le
conseil consultatif national d'éthique
avec le conseil pour la santé publique
avec les sociétés sabords de
gérontologie avec les fédérations les
directions des ehpad systématiquement et
le retour d'expérience notamment à
l'étranger où la situation était bien
plus catastrophique encore bien plus
catastrophique avec un virus qui
rentrait dans bien plus d'endroits qu'en
france nous a conduits à prendre des
décisions difficiles mais des décisions
pour protéger aujourd'hui quelle est la
situation vous fait vous ne faites pas
le lien entre deux constats vous parlez
de l'épuisement des soignants et vous
parlez des conditions encore drastique
d'entrer dans les ehpad fait le lien
entre les deux mâles valentin ou
interroger des directeurs d'ehpad et
vous verrez et vous verrez avec eux
qu'en réalité les directions d pad
les fédérations des ehpad pour un
certain nombre d'entre elles nous
demandent d'être encore vigilant d'être
encore prudent parce que au dernier
décompte il y avait encore 45% des ehpad
de notre pays qui déclarait des quatre
coronavirus et quand un virus il
rentrait dans un ehpad madame la députée
il y fait beaucoup de dégâts beaucoup de
dégâts sachez que je n'ai pas attendu le
5 juin pour simplifier ou alléger les
contraintes pour les familles ça a été
fait à deux reprises une première fois
début mai contrairement à ce que vous
dites est une deuxième fois le 5 juin il
y aura une troisième fois dans quelques
jours je l'espère sachez que les
familles peuvent aller visiter leurs
proches en ehpad et c'est heureux sur
place allaient dans la chambre du
résident y compris avec des enfants
s'ils pensent qu'ils peuvent porter un
masque le respect des gestes barrières
s'imposent ils peuvent aller dans le
jardin ou dans la cour de
l'établissement avec la personne
résidente
mais encore une fois malin valentin s'il
ya des directeurs d'établissements qui
considère que la situation est trop
tendue
trop à risque qu'il y ait encore des cas
avec des personnes qui sont malades
il est de leur responsabilité
aujourd'hui il est de leur
responsabilité de devoir mais des
contraintes plus importante le protocole
national vous le connaissez ce n'est en
aucun cas les agences régionales de
santé qu'ils adaptent au niveau du nez
donc à part car une fois pour protéger
la parole est un monsieur francis
vercamer
merci monsieur le président permettez
moi d'abord de préciser qu'il s'agit
pour moi aussi de ma dernière
intervention dans cet hémicycle
je viens d'être élu maire de hem dans le
nord et je m'apprête donc à quitter les
bancs de cette assemblée dont j'ai
l'honneur de faire partie depuis 2002
j'aurai donc au prélable remercier
l'ensemble de nos colllègues pour la
richesse des débats et la diversité nos
échanges représenter de concitoyens
échanger et débattre c'est l'essence
même de la démocratie c'est l'honneur du
parlement
je citerai andré diligent qui fut député
avant de devenir maire de roubaix puis
sénateur qui écrivait on n'est jamais
sûr d'avoir raison mais on sait si on a
été sincère et si on a su rester fidèle
à sa part de vérité
je voudrais aussi et je crois que chacun
partagera cet avis remercier l'ensemble
des personnels de cette assemblée dont
le professionnalisme et le dévouement
sont pour beaucoup dans la qualité du
travail de l'assemblée nationale
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre
lutter contre les discriminations accès
aux soins suffisants pour les plus
vulnérables inégalités territoriales
isolement social inégalités d'accès aux
services publics
ce sont là autant de thèmes qui sont
abordés par le défenseur des droits
dans le rapport d'activités 2010 9 qui
l'a rendu public hier
ces thèmes recoupe les réalité
quotidienne vécue par beaucoup de mes
concitoyens de l'agglomération
roubaisienne où se concentrent les
difficultés sociales les plus criantes
comme se concentre aussi les énergies
les initiatives locales les plus
innovantes qui donne foi en l'avenir
le sentiment d'abandon que souligne
pourtant le défenseur de droits et que
ressentent nombre de nos concitoyens
joue sans doute aussi un rôle dans
l'élan d'indignation et de colère qui
s'élève un peu partout dans le monde et
dans notre pays devant le drame que
viennent de connaître les états unis
qu'il s'agit d'égalité des droits ou des
chances de rénovation urbaine de nos
quartiers populaires d'accès à l'emploi
de droit à la santé
c'est surtout de la cohésion sociale de
dont il s'agit cohésion menacé pourtant
heureusement toujours présente monsieur
le premier ministre
l'initiative l'état autant t-il lancé
pour préserver et renforcer cette
cohésion sociale merci chers collègues
et accepte également nos félicitations
et tous nos voeux de succès dans le
nouveau mandat que vous allez exercer la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député permettez moi à travers la
réponse que je vais apporter à la
question que vous me posez de commencer
par féliciter tous ceux qui manquent de
cette assemblée ayant été brillamment
élu aux élections municipales font le
choix de consacrer à temps plein leur
vie politique future à ses fonctions
municipales que vous connaissez monsieur
le député pour les avoir déjà exercé
pendant longtemps et que vous retrouvez
je le sais avec avec plaisir et avec
envie je respecte ce choix
mais je le comprends
vous avez vous avez pendant des années
monsieur le député tenter de faire
avancer une cause qui vous est chère
celle de la cohésion sociale
c'est le de la capacité de notre pays à
vérifier qu'il ne s'écroule pas qu'il
reste bien en tant que nation ensemble
qu'il défend ses valeurs
c'est un exercice qui cotent il est
formulé comme cela peut paraître assez
simple mais vous savez que c'est une
tâche toujours renouvelée la cohésion
sociale et les questions qui ont été
posées cet après-midi le montre
parfaitement
c'est un ensemble de domaines où l'on
intervient sur les valeurs sur
l'éducation sur l'investissement sur la
lutte contre la pauvreté sur les
équipements publics la lutte la lutte
oui l'exercice la mission que vous êtes
confié que beaucoup ici partage de
préserver la cohésion sociale
c'est exactement le sens de la réponse
que je faisais à monsieur le député peu
sur le fait qu'il fallait mettre le
paquet si j'ose dire dans des endroits
de la république où la situation est
objectivement plus difficile c'est
exactement le sens de la réponse qui a
porté toute à l'heure julien de
normandie sur les efforts particuliers
que nous voulons apporter pendant l'été
que nous allons connaître auprès de
française de français auprès d'enfants
qui à cause de la crise sanitaire à
cause de la déscolarisation qu'ils ont
pu ressentir souhaitent bénéficier
pendant l'été de programmes adaptés qui
leur permettra de mieux reprendre au
mois de septembre
c'est aussi un exercice de cohésion
sociale la réponse que j'ai apportée
tout à l'heure à cette lutte
malheureusement éternel vers laquelle il
ne faut jamais renoncer contre le
racisme contre l'antisémitisme contre
l'ensemble de ces discriminations qui
parce que l'on n'est jamais identique à
l'autre voudrait que l'on ne soit pas
son égal
cet exercice collectif il sera je le
crains toujours nécessaire mais nous ne
nous battons pas dans l'espoir
d'avoir un jour à nous reposer nous nous
battons parce que nous savons que il
faut avancer encore et encore et que les
difficultés ont beau être immense la
france que vous avez servi et que vous
allez encore servir mérite qu on aille
jusqu'au bout
merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est à madame à aynac urique
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères j'y
associe ma collègue laure de la raudière
en 1984 la chine et le royaume-uni
dresser les modalités de la rétrocession
hong kongaise selon un principe un pays
deux systèmes
un principe confirmé en 97 à travers la
loi fondamentale de hong kong qui
garantit à l'ancienne colonie
britannique la préservation de ses
droits et libertés pour une période de
50 ans les atteintes à l'encontre du
particularisme légal de la région
administrative se font pourtant de plus
en plus grande et nous nous dirigeons
indéniablement vers le principe un pays
un système
raison de la mobilisation des
manifestants hong kong et en 2014 une
série de rassemblements pacifiques
demandé l'instauration d'un suffrage
universel plein et entier pour
l'élection du chef de l'exécutif les
difficile de penser qu'un pays comme la
chine dont la civilisation à dominer le
monde par sa richesse et son inventivité
durant des millénaires soit
fondamentalement mis en danger par
l'application de la démocratie à son
peuple
la pandémie de kobe de 19 à un temps
marqué un coup d'arrêt à la mobilisation
mais la loi visant à sauvegarder la
sécurité nationale à hong kong
adoptée le 28 mai dernier par le
parlement chinois est venue raviver les
craintes du peuble hong kong est ce
texte qui vient sur le papier interdire
les actes de trahison de sécession et de
subversion contre le pouvoir central
vient dans les faits mettre fin aux
relative degré d'autonomie dont il
jouissait jusqu'à présent le chef d'état
britanniques américains canadiens et
australiens ont
ont déjà annoncé au pouvoir central que
le pouvoir central est en contradiction
directe avec ses engagements
internationaux
s'il continue dans cette voie le royaume
uni ira plus loin encore en ouvrant 2,6
à 2,5 millions de hong kong est un
passeport permettant de travailler de
séjourner sur le territoire britannique
pendant six mois monsieur le ministre
comment la france peut-elle plaidé aux
côtés de ses partenaires internationaux
et surtout européens pour que la chine
respecte ses engagements jusqu'en 2047
date à laquelle le statut de hong kong
expirera je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur jean baptiste lemoyne
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
mesdames la députée aïnats khoury
permettez moi tout d'abord d'excusés
jean yves le drian mise de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères est en effet en
déplacement en république démocratique
du congo notamment pour participer à ce
pont aérien qui était mise en place par
les européens au côté des états et
peuples d'afrique afin de lutter
ensemble contre l'épidémie de covile 19
car oui l'europe est la bonne échelle
pour appréhender un certain nombre de
situations et s'agissant justement de la
situation de hong kong que vous évoquez
madame la députée dès le 22 mai dernier
les européens des états européens et
notamment la france se sont exprimés
d'une seule voix pour dire leur vive et
grave préoccupation
nous avons appelé à deux reprises notre
attachement au degré d'autonomie de ce
territoire et qui est garantie par ce
principe un pays deux systèmes
un principe qui a fait le succès et la
prospérité de hong kong
nous avons aussi indiqué avec nos
partenaires européens puisque vous
évoquez cette action européenne
l'importance que nous accordions au
respect de l'état de droit des libertés
fondamentales de l'indépendance de la
justice garantis par la loi fondamentale
de hong kong
jean yves le drian l'a rappelé à
plusieurs reprises cet attachement de la
france au respect de ces principes le
président la république lui même a pu
évoquer ce point lors avec son homologue
le président xi jinping lors d'un
entretien vendredi dernier nous
continuerons naturellement de suivre la
situation attentivement
lundi prochain les ministres des
affaires étrangères européens se
retrouvent en format conseil affaires
étrangères et les prochaines semaines
également comprennent un certain nombre
de rendez vous entre l'union européenne
et la chine pour que ce suivi soit
effectif et que la question soit
soulevée dans le cadre du dialogue
permanent entre l'union européenne et la
chine
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre la parole de monsieur guillaume
chiche merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
voilà maintenant dix mois nous entamions
dans cette assemblée les travaux
parlementaires relatifs au projet de loi
de révision des lois de bioéthique dix
mois aux prémices desquelles nous avons
trouvé un équilibre entre ce qui était
techniquement possible et moralement
acceptable dis moi que cette assemblée a
exprimé sa volonté de donner les mêmes
droits à toutes les femmes mettant ainsi
fin à plusieurs décennies d'attenté de
revendications autour de chaque femme
pour chaque femme quelle que soit son
orientation sexuelle sont d'identité de
genre ou son statut matrimonial pour
accéder à une procréation médicalement
assistée prise en charge par la sécurité
sociale qu'elle puisse fonder famille
s'il ya le désir et bâtir un projet
parental qu'elles soient hétérosexuels
en couple lesbien ou célibataires
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous devons regarder la réalité en face
chaque jour que nous laissons s'écouler
est une chance en moins pour ces femmes
de mener à bien une aide médicale à la
procréation
chaque jour qui passe sa compagne de
femmes qui prennent des risques pour
leur santé en essayant de se rendre à
l'étranger pour recourir à des pma dans
des pays qui ne discrimine pas l'accès
d'une belle prison nullement l'impact
considérable de la crise sanitaire que
nous traversons et l'exigence de notre
modification de notre agenda
parlementaire pour faire face pour
autant mes chers collègues je tiens à
rappeler que cette crise a aussi été le
théâtre de nombreux traitements ou
processus de paix m a mise en péril par
la fermeture de services proposant cette
technique il y a dix jours avec 88
association avocats médecins
personnalités publiques et collègues
parlementaires de la majorité des
groupes ici présents
nous avons demandé d'inscrire le psg l
bioéthique en seconde lecture il ya
trois jours la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
brigitte bourguignon se réjouissait
publiquement d'un examen dès le mois de
juillet prochain
pouvez vous monsieur le ministre prendre
l'engagement devant la représentation
nationale d'inscrire ce projet de loi en
seconde lecture avant la fin du mois
d'août et donc avant la fin de la
session parlementaire
l'égalité des droits la santé monsieur
ne vivent pas votre société parole chez
olivier véran ministre des solidarités
et de la santé monsieur le député
guillaume chiche merci pour votre
question je vous sais très attaché à la
question de l'ouverture la pma à toutes
les femmes vous le savez aussi très
attaché à cette question comme vous le
savez attaché en général avec questions
bioéthiques et aux très nombreux progrès
que ce texte de loi que ce projet de loi
gouvernemental porte et qui a été
considérablement améliorée renforcer
dans bien des endroits par les
parlementaires eux mêmes à l'issue d'une
première lecture qui a eu lieu à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
la vision vous poser c'est à quand la
réalisation concrète
l'application concrète pour les femmes
qui attendent mais au rugby également
pour les enfants qui souhaitent accéder
aux origines mais également pour les
personnes qui sont atteintes de maladies
génétiques et bien d'autres sujets
primordiaux encore en tout cas
primordiaux haute au moins autant à mes
yeux que vôtre monsieur le député une
loi bioéthique nécessite je suis sûr
vous en conviendrez avec moi de pouvoir
mobiliser l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale sur l'ensemble
des bancs et donc nécessite que nous
soyons capables de réunir un maximum de
parlementaires me semble-t-il au sein de
l'hémicycle le choix qui a été fait par
le gouvernement était de ne pas procéder
lecture accélérée mais d'avoir un rythme
de lecture normal de manière à pouvoir
enrichir discuter ce texte
autant de fois que nécessaire moi je
vous le dit aussitôt que nous serons en
mesure sanitaire haute sitôt que les
conditions seront réunies qui nous
permettront d'examiner ce texte compter
sur moi comptez sur moi pour accompagner
toute démarche c'est le président la
république qui en décident de mise à
l'agenda parlementaire du texte pour une
deuxième lecture
rapidement je le souhaite je l'espère
vraiment peut-être que la commission
spéciale qui se réunit dans des
conditions différentes de l'hémicycle
commencé le travail en espérant que les
conditions sanitaires dont je ne peux
préjuger en l'état pour des raisons
évidentes et que vous comprenez en
attendant que l'assemblée nationale
puisse être en mesure de le faire est ce
que ce sera en juillet je l'espère je le
souhaite est ce que ce sera à la rentrée
de septembre
si nous n'arrivons pas à le faire en
juillet en tous les cas croyez-moi
croyant à la sincérité de ma démarche je
souhaite que nous puissions faire
examiner et aboutir ce texte pour ouvrir
des nouveaux droits d'ici à la fin de
l'année c'est à dire que nous avions
fini l'ensemble des lectures c'est pas
une mince affaire mais on y arrivera
parce qu'on en a tous très envie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame elsa faucillon merci monsieur
le président je ne peux pas respirer
ce sont cinq mots de souffrance
d'injustice de colère qui gronde dans le
monde entier ce sont ceux de georges
floyd mais aussi ceux d' adama traoré ou
de cédric joue via avant leur mort
et lors d'une interpellation policière
ces violences policières souvent
racistes sont une réalité et l abîme en
profondeur notre démocratie
elles laissent des familles endeuillées
et l enseigne la défiance enregistrement
racistes antisémites homophobes appel à
la guerre civile
interpellation à l'ile-saint-denis
rappelant les années papon passage à
tabac de gabriel 14 ans c'est
insupportable et il y a un problème dans
notre police républicaine le nier c'est
la promesse certaines d'une dangereuse
impasse
ces faits documentés et la déferlante
antiraciste mondial vous ont contraints
à réagir agissez maintenant ça traoré
demande le droit de participer à la
construction de ce monde de cette france
droits que les violences policières et
le racisme et toof les collectifs de
famille ou les associations comme vie
volée demande l'interdiction des
pratiques l'ecc talent oui il faut
interdire la clé d'étranglement
oui mais le placage ventrale existe et
présentent le même risque
même sans pression au niveau de la nique
ou du coup ces sept tergiverser
bannissez le la visibilité du
numéro rio des agents de police et déjà
une obligation
elle est pourtant rarement appliquée sur
le contrôle d'identité vous pointer un
problème d'ampleur mais vous vous
contentez de rappeler le cadre existant
quant à l'igpn vous la laisse est juge
et partie
monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous rétablir la confiance dans
la police sans mettre fin à l'impunité
de ces individus violents sans
transformer l'igpn en instance
impartiale et indépendante sans vous
attaquez réellement aux contrôles au
faciès dont vous niez encore l'ampleur
le président de la république s'est ému
de la justesse du film les misérables
depuis on a l'impression qu'il a perdu
sa voix merci de débuter la parole et à
monsieur laurent munier secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la députée vous évoquez dans
votre question plusieurs thématiques et
évidemment je ne peux commencer cette
réponse sans vous dire non madame la
députée la police n'est pas raciste non
madame la députée la police n'est pas
violente comme pardon pardon vous pouvez
le sous-entend je souhaite vraiment
apporté cette précision d'abord la
police n'est pas raciste
oui il y a eu des faits et vous les avez
cités oui il y a eu des faits madame la
députée qui ont été sanctionnés des
faits ou des actes ont pu être commis et
qui se rattache aux racines des propos
racistes ont pu être retenues et des
sanctions ont été mises en oeuvre des
procédures judiciaires sont ouvertes et
le ministre de l'intérieur l'a annoncé
hier
nous irons encore plus loin puisqu'il y
aura désormais quand les faits sont
avérés des suspensions automatiques et
bien évidemment justifier ça c'est
quelque chose de nouveau qui va
renforcer la politique résolue de lutte
contre le racisme contre les faits
racistes dans la police que nous mettons
en oeuvre
non madame la députée la police n'est
pas violente la police exerce une
violence légitime
lorsqu'elle est prise à partie lorsque
il y à des dégradations
lorsque les forces de l'ordre sont
prises à partie dans le cadre de
manifestations la police oui alors fait
usage d'une violence légitime sous le
contrôle de l'autorité judiciaire sous
le contrôle de l'inspection générale de
la police nationale
hier le ministre de l'intérieur a
annoncé une mesure importante
fondamentale celle qui verra
l'inspection générale de
l'administration pouvoir se saisir d'un
certain nombre d' enquête administrative
quand il y aura des suspicions de
violences policières et comme cela avait
été fait dans la sphère steve à nantes
mener des investigations en
administratifs qui sont dès qu'ils
seront des investigations complètes qui
seront menées je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire madame la députée ce que
vous avez dit je suis désolée
la police n'est pas raciste la police
n'est pas violente
cette police et celle qui tous les jours
lutte contre la délinquance lutte contre
le terrorisme lutte contre les trafics
de stupéfiants et protège la liberté de
manifester des manifestants comme ils le
font tous les jours voilà ce que la
police républicaine dans notre pays
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame anne laurence peut-elle et à
elle seule
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre
huit minutes 46 secondes c'est le temps
qu'il a fallu pour que l'interpellation
de georges floyd se transforme en
homicide à minneapolis le 25 mai dernier
cet événement indigné le monde entier et
a réveillé une colère qui s'étend à tous
les continents
la france n'échappe pas à cette colère
ni à ses vieux démons
les faits racistes et xénophobes ont
augmenté de 130% en 2019
cette réalité insupportable touche toute
la société
elle n'épargne pas la police vous l'avez
dit hier monsieur le ministre et encore
ce matin le racisme n'a pas sa place
dans notre société
et encore moins dans notre police
républicaine
mais si les actes de quelques-uns
salisse l'honneur de la police ils ne
doivent pas faire oublier et vous l'avez
rappelé que chaque jour des femmes et
des hommes en uniforme veille sur nous
et nous protège et qu'ils risquent leur
vie pour cela
non notre police n'est pas raciste mais
il y à des racistes en son sein non il
n'y a pas de violence institutionnalisée
il y a des comportements violents à
bannir pouvons-nous tolérer qu'un enfant
de 14 ans sortent d'une garde à vue avec
le visage tuméfié
non pouvons-nous tolérer qu'un gendarme
soit roué de coups lors d'une
manifestation non plus
quand nos oppositions joue au pyromane
en imposant aux français de choisir un
camp quand la polémique précède de
l'information comment lutter contre les
discriminations et réconcilier en même
temps c'est votre mission et elle est
ardu vous porter l'ambition d'une police
du 21ème siècle et cette réforme vous
l'avait commencée avec la police de
sécurité du quotidien avec les
conférences citoyennes pour rédiger le
livre blanc de la sécurité intérieure
hier vous avez annoncé une réforme des
inspections la fin de l'enseignement de
techniques dangereuses plus de formation
continue pour les forces de l'ordre le
chemin que vous montrez celui d'une
exigence d'exemplarité une compréhension
mutuels et un respect des lois et des
règles par tous la confiance ne se
décrète pas elle se construit petit à
petit c'est le sens de votre engagement
aussi quelles mesures complémentaires
comptez-vous prendre monsieur nice pour
réussir cette police de la confiance et
de monsieur christophe castaner ministre
de l'intérieur merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les députés
madame la députée anne laurence pétel le
racisme constitue un mal
un mal qui gangrène notre société vous
l'avait dit et nous comptons bien avec
laurent nyonnaise et à travers la
réponse qu'il vient de porter éradiquer
cette tumeur maligne qui n'a pas sa
place dans les forces de police mais
vous l'avez dit laurent nunès va
rappeler à l'instant il n'y a pas de
police violente
il n'y a pas de police raciste il peut y
avoir des femmes et des hommes qui faute
il peut y avoir des femmes et des hommes
qui sont racistes et se comporte ainsi
et nous devons être exemplaires sur ce
sujet mais que les choses soient dites
comme vous venez le fer avec clarté avec
fermeté mais sans amalgame je
n'accepterai jamais madame la députée je
n'accepterai jamais les insultes les
amalgames les mises en cause les
déclarations à l'emporte-pièce contre
nos forces de sécurité intérieure je les
défendrai comme je lai toujours fait
avec la même énergie avec la même
exigence
parce que soutenir nos forces de
sécurité intérieure c'est toujours
contribué à les accompagner vers le haut
vers l'exemplarité vers les tic 20 la
déontologie et il n'est pas question que
quelques brebis galeuses et c'est le mot
que j'ai évoqué hier puisse nuire à la
force et au respect que nous devons à
nos policiers et à nos gendarmes
j'annonçais madame la députée hier une
série de mesures que nous devons
construire encore avec les policiers
avec les gendarmes au plus près du
terrain
une série de mesures qui visent
justement à travailler sur ce rapport de
confiance entre la police et la
population nous le savons il s'est
dégradé ces derniers temps il est utile
de regarder aussi la réalité en face et
avec ce plan d'action que nous devons
construire au plus près du terrain avec
les femmes et les hommes qui chaque jour
chaque nuit protège les français et font
l'honneur de la police et de la
gendarmerie
nous réussirons à combattre le racisme
un mot titren depuis 30 ans et ce qui
souvent met en cause la police et que
trop souvent on a voulu balayer sous le
tapis
la parole est à monsieur ugo bernalicis
monsieur le premier ministre je suis
satisfait que vous ayez enfin pris
conscience des rapports dégradé et
préoccupant entre la police et la
population et le péril que cela
constitue pour l'unité du peuple
français mais nous voulons avec notre
groupe de la france insoumise d'abord
remercier celles et ceux qui ont permis
cette prise de conscience en se
mobilisant à travers le monde et en
france contre les violences policières
et les discriminations
la mobilisation se fait trop souvent
dans l'indifférence et l'opprobre pour
que les victimes obtiennent justice et
vérité
singulièrement il faut remercier ces
policiers qui petit à petit brise
l'omerta et faut connaître leurs
collègues raciste qui n'ont rien à faire
dans la police républicaine
vous semblez désormais partager notre
objectif de rétablir une police
républicaine
la police ne doit pas être crainte elle
doit être respectée et pour cela elle
doit être respectable en étant
débarrassé de ses éléments violents
racistes et anti républicain une police
a de l'autorité quand elle est respectée
elle est respectée quand elle est
légitime c'est-à-dire quand elle agit
avec proportionnalité et déontologie
finissons-en une bonne fois pour toutes
avec les forces de l'ordre
rétablissons les gardiens de la paix
nous avons proposé le récépissé de
contrôle d'identité l'interdiction des
ailes bd des grenades explosives
l'interdiction comme dans d'autres pays
des techniques qui peuvent tuer de
pliage et de plaquages ventrale vous
avez tous rejetés nous vous les
proposons à nouveau et deux autres
réformes sont indispensables d'abord le
contrôle interne de l'igpn doit être
rendue indépendant et le contrôle
externe du défenseur des droits
renforcés 36 demandes de sanction sur
4000 saisine du défenseur des droits
c'est déjà un énorme filtre avec à la
clé 0 sanctions c'est inacceptable
ensuite au sujet de la formation
initiale et continue cela fait trois ans
que je vous demande d'ouvrir les écoles
de police que nicolas sarkozy a fermé en
son temps pour revenir à un an de
formation initiale afin d'armer
intellectuellement la police pour
répondre aux attentes de la population
le candidat maquereau en 2017 disait ce
n'est pas possible quand il ya une
violence policière qu'il n'y ait aucune
sanction dans la hiérarchie policière
il y à un commissaire de police un
directeur départemental de la sécurité
publique un préfet il y a un ministre
alors je vous le demande solennellement
pour rétablir la confiance du peuple en
sa à sa police de changer ce qui à la
tête ont couvert pendant trop longtemps
cette réalité notamment le ministre
castaner et le préfet l'allemand merci
monsieur le député l'état monsieur
laurent munier secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre de l'intérieur
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
en vous écoutant je ne peux que
commencer en vous en vous en vous
rappelant d'abord qu'il n'est pas
question de rétablir la police
républicaine la police française est une
police républicaine
la question que vous posez elles
touchent directement finalement
finalement à la relation entre la police
et la population
vous savez que cette relation elle est
une relation de confiance elle est
essentielle les policiers les gendarmes
et les gendarmes sont des piliers de la
république ce sont eux qui lutte contre
la délinquance et personne ne nie la
qualité de leurs actions dans ce pays je
dis bien personne
alors oui la relation entre la police et
la population elle c'est rod elle c'est
rod peut être aussi en partie parce que
pendant certaines manifestations quand
les forces de l'ordre étaient pris à
partie certains sur vauban ont pu dire
que la police était utilisée par le
pouvoir politique pour réprimer des
manifestations pour réprimer une
expression oui ce type de propos héros
de la relation de confiance entre la
police et la population
oui
oui dans d'autres territoires dans
d'autres territoires la moindre
implication d'acteurs qui sont des
acteurs importants pour la sécurité
parfois certaines communes parfois
certains bailleurs parfois recettes à
transporter leur moindre implication
dans ce que nous souhaitons mettre en
oeuvre ce partenariat de sécurité entre
tous fait que trop souvent nos forces de
police nos forces de gendarmerie sont
finalement les seuls respecte réceptacle
des problèmes de sécurité
et ça c'est un problème nous sommes en
train de le résoudre avec la mise en
place de la sécurité du quotidien pour
qui seule une île ne soit pas seule
confrontée parfois à la gestion
d'incivilités et ils sont parfois seul
être confrontée à ces difficultés et
ceux qui génèrent souvent effectivement
d une dégradation de la relation et
c'est sur quoi nous travaillons
et puis enfin vous avez raison mais nous
ne le nions pas avec le ministre de
l'intérieur effectivement cette
dégradation de la relation
elle est aussi dû au comportement d'un
certain nombre de policiers ou de
gendarmes qu'ils peuvent commettre des
fautes mais heureusement ces fautes sont
minoritaires et heureusement elle donne
toujours lieu à enquête judiciaire
administrative est systématiquement à
sanction je ne mens pas monsieur le
député je vous rappelle qu'il y avait
1500 près 1500 enquêtes judiciaires
engagées en 2019 et plus et autant
quasiment autant de sanctions
administratives et près de 2000
sanctions pour les rssi monsieur vais
pas dire vieux lévis dans ce long
travail dans l'impunité c'est merci
monsieur mu la parole de monsieur bruno
duvergé merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur ministre la crise du coc vie de
19 à bouleverser les habitudes
professionnelles des enseignants
ceux ci font preuve d'un sens du service
public exemplaire par leur disponibilité
leur attention à la réussite de nos
jeunes ils ont profondément marqué les
esprits à ce titre je tiens notamment à
souligner l'engagement important des
directeurs d'école primaire
en effet ce sont eux qui durant cette
crise ont continué à faire le lien avec
l'ensemble des parents d'élèves ont
organisé la mise en place des cours en
distance yale ou en présentiel se sont
chargés de mettre en oeuvre les
dispositifs sanitaires nécessaires à la
réouverture des écoles se sont
appropriés
approvisionné en gel en masques et en
produits désinfectants
or comme vous le savez ces directeurs
d'école demeurent des enseignants comme
les autres pourtant dans ma
circonscription dans la commune de
frévent l'école élémentaire publique qui
compte plus d'élèves que le collège
public d'à côté ne disposent pas des
mêmes moyens humains et matériels pour
accueillir les élèves
si à partir de 14 classes la décharge de
cours et complète pour les directeurs du
primaire
il n'en demeure pas moins que leur
statut ne leur permet pas à l'heure
actuelle d'organiser d'animer la vie
scolaire de manière plus autonome
monsieur le ministre je pense qu'il est
temps de renforcer et de valoriser la
fonction de directeur d'école au regard
des responsabilités qui sont les leurs
de leurs investissements pour la
communauté éducative
nous devons nous engager pour leur
donner les moyens d'exercer leurs
missions
stimulés coordonnées encourager et
harmoniser les initiatives de l'équipe
pédagogique
tout ceci sans remettre en cause
l'autorité de l'inspection académique
quelles sont les pistes que vous
entendez suivre à ce sujet je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole et à
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
bruno duvergé tout ce que vous avez dit
est profondément juste et je veux vous
en remercier d'abord sur le constat le
constat que vous faites de l'immense
dévouement des directeurs et directrices
d'école ça c'est beaucoup vu pendant la
période de confinement j'ai en tête ce
qui a été fait je me souviens de
directrice que j'avais à au téléphone
qui allaient dans les familles portent
et les devoirs qui téléphonait pour
s'assurer qu'il n'y avait pas de
décrochage
ce dévouement s'est vu tout
particulièrement même s'il n'était que
le reflet de ce qui se passe en réalité
toute l'année pendant le déconfinement
la fonction évolue encore il ya de
nouvelles contraintes
nous savons tous que le protocole
sanitaire représente une contrainte
nécessaire mais très forte et avec le
premier ministre sous l'impulsion du
président de la république nous voulons
aller vers l' allègement progressif en
fonction de la situation sanitaire et je
tiens à le dire parce que ça aussi ça
changera leur leur vie quotidienne et
nous y travaillons
et puis il ya les sujets structurelles
vous les avez évoqué peu de gens savent
ce que vous avez dit c'est à dire le
fait que les directeurs d'école n'ont
pas de véritable statut
c'est un sujet à discussion depuis fort
longtemps dans le système scolaire ce
n'est pas un sujet de consensus
il ya eu un très gros travail fait par
une parlementaire en particulier la
députée cécile relax mais aussi par
d'autres parlementaires et de même que
madame marchand de même que les
sénateurs bref il y a eu un mûrissement
de ce sujet de sorte qu'il ya une
proposition de loi dans le sens d'un
renforcement des directeurs d'école nous
en parlons nous avons besoin d'eux
encore du dialogue sur cette question
parce que nous avons un besoin besoin à
la fois d renforcée administrativement
d'alléger leurs tâches administratives
de leur donner quelque chose qui soit
une reconnaissance de direction pas
seulement sous l'angle financier mais
aussi sous l'angle de leur statut ou de
leur fonction en tout cas tout ceci va
encore faire débat nous en parlerons en
commission éducation et culture bientôt
je prendrais forcément des mesures pour
la rentrée prochaine qui sont le fruit
de ce débat et puis nous continuerons
d'un point de vue législatif aussi je
l'espère je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur olivier faure président le
malaise est profond
il y a cinq ans le chanteur renaud
embrasser un flic comment depuis en
sommes nous arrivés cette rupture de
confiance entre nos concitoyens et ce
qui les protège
parfois même au péril de leur vie en
janvier déjà
après le décès de cédric souvient votre
gouvernement avait assuré revenir sur
les modalités de contrôle puis rien
après être resté sourd à toutes les
alertes pendant deux ans votre ministre
de l'intérieur a enfin fait un pas de
côté hier insuffisants les clé
d'étranglement ne seront plus enseigner
mais seront elles interdites
notre pays s'honorerait par ailleurs
après tant d'autres en europe à
proscrire les lbd les grenades mutilante
et le placage ventrale à l'origine de
trop nombreuses blessures irréversibles
la police n'était lasse pas épargné par
le poison du racisme
lorsque les faits sont constatés ils
doivent être immédiatement et durement
sanctionnés
les contrôles d'identité permanent
conséquence absurde d'une politique du
chiffre ne peuvent plus être
discriminatoire la police républicaine
doit être exemplaire
la transparence enfin doit être totale
l'igpn et les gènes ne trouveront leur
pleine crédibilité qu en
s'affranchissant de la tutelle du
ministre de l'intérieur la légitimité de
vos institutions se fonde sur l'accord
entre les valeurs les buts et les
comportements
c'est pourquoi je vous annonce que le
groupe socialiste demandera une
commission d enquête parlementaire sur
les violences policières
elle devra prendre la dimension réelle
du sujet et débouché sur les mesures de
nature à réconcilier les français avec
leur police les policiers les gendarmes
mérite notre respect mais il n'y a pas
d'ordre sans justice
merci chers collègues la parole l'état
monsieur christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs étiez monsieur le député
olivier faure le maintien de l'ordre la
sécurité publique ce rapport entre la
police et la cie et nos citoyens et la
citoyenneté sont quelque chose
d'éminemment sérieux qui implique
notamment d'avoir un peu de mémoire
vous évoquez à l'instant le récit pisser
sur les contrôles d'identité j'ai le
souvenir que nous étions il ya peu de
temps dans la même majorité au moment où
cette majorité n'a pas souhaité mettre
en place les récits pitt et d'identité
géante est aussi un certain nombre de
faits qui mettent en cause ce que vous
appelez le placage ventrale et je serai
donc le premier ministre de l'intérieur
a pris cette décision d'interdire malgré
la grogne que cela provoque malgré les
inquiétudes aussi pour nos forces de
sécurité qui doivent avoir les moyens de
continuer à intervenir sur le terrain
celui qui a interdit effectivement
l'étranglement parce que c'est une
pratique qui est très rare au niveau
mondial et qui se pratique aujourd'hui
encore et donc j'ai pris la décision que
très vite nos forces soient formés pour
substituer d'autres méthodes
d'intervention avec d'autres moyens
d'intervention et je pense monsieur le
député que c'est une vraie avancée dont
vous pourriez à
fois la saluer et peut-être même être un
peu fier d'avoir contribué à cette
avancée là monsieur le député je crois
qu'il est essentiel de non pas
stigmatiser mais de soutenir aux fausses
innocences de sécurité non monsieur le
député il n'y a pas de rupture de
confiance non monsieur le député il n'y
a pas de rupture de confiance entre les
français et la police aujourd'hui une
très large majorité de français soutient
la police et c'est cela la réalité il ya
peu de temps une étude réalisée par
l'université savoie-mont-blanc indiqué
que 82% des 13000 personnes qui ont été
testées confirmé leur soutien net clair
et franc à la police mais cela n'empêche
pas monsieur le député que nous soyons
particulièrement exigeant et c'est cette
exigence que je porte parce que je
soutiens la police j'attends d'elle
qu'elle soit exemplaire et je lui en
donne les moyens monsieur le député
merci monsieur le ministre pour la
dernière question pour la fin monsieur
aurélien pradié la question s'adresse à
la ministre de la justice madame la
ministre
j'ai honte je ne sais pas vous mais moi
j'ai honte j'ai honte d'avoir découvert
le 27 juin dernier un décret publié en
catimini signé de votre main et qui acte
un incroyable recul dans la protection
des femmes victimes de violences
le 15 octobre dernier j'ai eu l'honneur
de porter devant notre assemblée une loi
votée à l'unanimité cette loi permettait
enfin de passer des paroles aux actes en
accélérant les procédures et en
généralisant le bras c'est anti
rapprochement mais qu'avez vous fait de
cette loi depuis le 1er janvier et son
entrée en application combien de
bracelet anti rapprochement ont été
achetés par la france combien de ces
salopards se sont vus imposer le port de
ce bras c'est combien
aucun 0 rien non seulement vous n'avez
pas avancé mais vous avez régressé notre
loi fixé à 6 jours un délai maximum pour
qu'une ordonnance de protection soit
délivré à une femme en danger votre
décret vient détruire cette avancée vous
venez de fixer une nouvelle contrainte
intenable en demandant aux victimes de
payer elle même de leur poche un
huissier pour notifier
vous demandez aux victimes de convoquer
elles mêmes leurs propres bourreaux et
si les victimes ne tiennent pas ce délai
intenable de 24 heures vous osez annulé
la procédure
vous tuez l'ordonance de protection la
colère aujourd'hui je ne la retient dre
pas c'est la colère de ces milliers de
femmes en danger qui vous entendre dire
blanc et vous vois faire noir qui voit
une secrétaire d'état encore absente
aujourd'hui bavasser sur les plateaux de
télévision
alors que l'essentiel n'est jamais fait
c'est la colère d'un député qui a porté
une loi et qui vous voilà défaire je
vous demande madame la ministre
solennellement de retirer sur le champ
ce décret la parole est à madame nicole
belloubet garde des sceaux ministre de
la justice
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
députés messieurs les députés monsieur
le député pradier les mots cinglants
n'ont jamais fait une politique publique
les vôtres pas plus que d'autres et je
tiens à vous dire ici que c'est parce
que ce gouvernement a la volonté de
lutter contre les violences faites aux
femmes que les ordonnances de protection
ont été délivrés plus nombreuses cette
année que le nombre de féminicide chacun
d'eux étant un drame tend à décroître
que tous les tribunaux se sont mis en
ordre de marche pour délivrer les
ordonnances de protection et c'est cela
que nous voulons continuer à faire
c'est la raison pour laquelle dès demain
matin je réunirai avec la haute
fonctionnaire chargé de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes au sein du
ministère de la justice je réunirai les
associations les professionnels pour
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre les
dispositions qui ont été votées par le
parlement lors de la loi du 28 décembre
dernier et notamment la possibilité de
délivrer en six jours les ordonnances de
protection pour cela nous avons pris un
décret pour cela nous avons prévu de
tout mettre en oeuvre pour que ces
ordonnances soient délivrés dans le
respect du principe du contradictoire et
c'est pour cela que nous avons proposé
un texte qui donne un délai pour
informer le défendeur je ne les dit si
les associations si les professionnels
si le comité de pilotage que je viens
demain
on oeuvre nous dit que ce n'est pas
réalisable pratiquement je n'aurai
aucune hésitation je n'aurai aucune
hésitation je me dis fierais ce texte je
ne modifierai vite et sans hésiter merci
madame le garde des sceaux monsieur le
député merci monsieur le président
madame la garde des sceaux les actes
faibles n'ont jamais fait une politique
publique vous bricoler nous connaissons
les solutions retirer ce décret qui
neutralise les ordonnances de protection
et fait confiance au travail que nous
avons déjà effectué ici au parlement
merci monsieur le député madame la
ministre monsieur le député je suis
vraiment désolé mais le mensonge n'est
pas une politique vraiment pas et ce que
nous avons construit ce que nous avons
construit nous le faisons pour les
femmes
et d'abord pour elle c'est notre seul
objectif c'est notre seule boussole la
séance des questions au gouvernement et
terminer la séance est suspendue